l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement je voudrais me réjouir du
nombre de députés présents ce matin en
séance
75 députés peuvent désormais se réunir
dans l'hémicycle sur une répartition
proportionnelle aux effectifs des
groupes
ce nombre compte tenu des ministres des
fonctionnaires permet de respecter le
décret qui limite à 100 personnes n'est
rassemblement en milieu clos sur tout le
territoire de la république
par ailleurs nous revenons aujourd'hui
au nombre habituel de questions plus
favorable au groupe d'opposition les
temps de parole sont les temps usuel de
minutes par question et autant par
raiponce réplique ou contre réplique
éventuellement comprise l'ordre d'appel
traditionnel des questions et rétablit
toutefois les questions ayant le même
thème continueront d'être regroupés
chaque question faisant l'objet d'une
réponse spécifique les règles sanitaires
continuent à s'appliquer nettoyage des
micros encore l'océan c'est les orateurs
sont invités à ne pas poser les mains
sur les micro et à utiliser des micros
différents respect des distances entre
les participants entrée et sortie
échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du club
et 19 en général et notamment le thème
de la santé
la parole est à monsieur le président
bertrand penchèrent se prémunissent
mentionné c'est plus une question posée
à monsieur le ministre de la santé
est-ce que vous coordonnez un seul
ministre les acquisitions et
distribution de masques pour l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé
je pense notamment aux dentistes qui
n'ont tous alerté récemment en nous
disant qu'ils n'avaient plus qu'une
semaine de stocks de masques
il en faut 15 masques environ par par
dentiste par par semaine tout simplement
parce qu'ils ont tout donné ils ont
d'ailleurs fait beaucoup de
communication pour vous alerter sur ce
sujet je pense notamment aux taxis qui
souvent transportent des malades
notamment en milieu rural
mama fédérations de taxi me dit on se
débrouille actuellement tout seul et il
ya eu des quatre coronavirus danse et
dans ses sociétés de taxis et puis si
vous avez quelques minutes peut-être
pour répondre à la question que tout le
monde se pose
lié à l'information sur les défaillances
cardiaques se signaler au chalet chez
les enfants qui inquiète qui inquiète
beaucoup de parents lle liés aux
coronavirus est ce que vous avez des
informations sur ce sujet notamment dans
le cadre de la rentrée scolaire futur
c'est une information utile
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député pencher compte tenu de la nature
de votre question je vous réponde
rapidement sur les masques notamment
salué l'effort qui a été réalisé par les
dentistes avec qui nous avons travaillé
de façon coordonnée depuis le début
qu'ils ont consenti à réduire voire
fermer leur cabinet pour permettre
d'utiliser les stocks de masques dans
les hôpitaux notamment
ils ont des besoins en masques ffp2 là
il ya des stockages 250 mille masques
pour leur permettre de tenir avec une
organisation d'urgence de manière à ne
gérer que les urgences non je crois 400
cabinets sur tout le territoire national
et à partir du 11 mai nous travaillons
avec eux de manière à leur permettre de
trouver les conditions qui leur
permettrait de reprendre une activité
normale ou la plus normale possible les
besoins en masques ffp2 s'élève à 800
milles par semaine ce que nous sommes en
train de voir c'est si nous pouvons leur
donner ce nombre précis de masques pour
leur permettre de reprendre une activité
mais à nouveau permettez moi de les
remercier pour leur organisation et je
sais les forts que ça a été pour eux et
leur caisse de retraite a fait une
proposition de mobiliser des fonds pour
les aider dans la période
si je suis favorable de la même manière
qu'il ya une discussion avec l'assurance
maladie qui est en train d'aboutir pour
des compensations de perte de revenus
pour l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé libéraux sur l' alerte parisienne
l'alerté anglaises espagnoles italiennes
il y à un certain nombre de situations
de d'inflammation cardiaque
d'inflammation artérielle
c'est environ ce sont environ 15 enfants
en france depuis la mi avril qui
présentent une maladie qui ressemble à
ce qu'on appelle la maladie de kawasaki
qui tue maladies inflammatoires qui peut
être déclenché d'ailleurs par des
maladies
infectieuse virale ou bactérienne qui
peut parfois être une réaction
secondaire à des maladies évidemment
comme toute alerte nous la prenons très
au sérieux
c'est le temps de la recherche clinique
de la recherche scientifique
l'ensemble des pédiatres des
réanimateurs de la zone euro travaillent
ensemble pour voir s'il ya lieu ou non
de faire un lien avec le co vie de 19 ce
que je ne sais pas encore au moment où
je vous parle
quelques-uns des enfants ont été testés
positifs au cofidis
d'autres noms en tout cas nous prenons
ça avec beaucoup de sérieux au niveau
international je communiquerai toutes
les informations à mesure que je les
aurai mais encore une fois à ce stade il
s'agit d'une alerte
et pas encore d'un constant merci
monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur hubert wulfranc monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation les impacts de
la crise sur la vie des enfants et des
jeunes entraîne des ruptures majeures
rupture éducatif graves carences
alimentaires troubles psychologiques
avec en toile de fond une accélération
des inégalités mais quelques mois avant
la rentrée de septembre risque encore de
détériorer la situation et les grandes
vacances dont de nombreuses familles ne
profitent déjà pas suffisamment n'ont
pas le même rôle bienfaisant cette
rentrée vous oblige donc à des décisions
fortes et bienveillante
nous vous demandons de renoncer à toute
fermeture de classe deux ordres
comptables et de renforcer les
dispositifs d'appui éducatif en primaire
avec plus de maîtres queux de classe au
collège et au lycée avec une
augmentation des heures d'enseignement
permettant de prendre en charge les
élèves en difficulté le remplacement
immédiat de chaque professeur absent
devra assurer une réelle continuité
pédagogique et vous prêterez attention à
lisser le rattrapage des programmes dans
le temps ces mesures supposent selon
nous d'augmenter les places au concours
des 7 années de titulariser les
personnels exerçant le métier depuis
plus de deux ans et d'aménager
précisément les programmes en
concertation avec les enseignants
nous vous demandons ensuite une
revalorisation des fonds sociaux
collégiens lycéens et étudiants pour
parer aux situations précaires qui vont
se multiplier
de la même manière un abondement des
financements d'état aux actions d'éveil
et de découverte doivent être examinés
enfin sans être complet nous vous
engageons à redresser rapidement et de
manière volontariste la place de la
médecine scolaire dans la vie des
établissements qui malheureusement
jusqu'à présent a été la grande absente
le budget pour la rentrée 2020 doit être
selon les députés communistes augmenté
est ce que cela sera le cas
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
hubert wulfranc je suis totalement
d'accord avec les prémices de votre
raisonnement
en effet il ya un risque d'aggravation
des inégalités nous l'avons pointés dès
le début du confinement
d'où la mobilisation générale de
l'éducation nationale avec d'ailleurs
tous les acteurs de la société
pour compenser au maximum ce risque
d'accentuation des inégalités
et oui les dégâts que vous parlez
psychologiques physiques alimentaires et
autres existent bel et bien et nous
avons à travailler pour qu'il faut qu'il
soit atténuer voire supprimés c'est le
sens aussi du déconfinement tel que nous
l'envisageons puisque précisément il est
fait pour commencer à remédier à ces
problèmes là et par exemple lutter
contre le décrochage
s'agissant de la préparation de rentrée
qui est au coeur de votre question comme
conséquence de ces problèmes d'inégalité
vous avez totalement raison il faut
avoir une vision d'exception par rapport
à ce qui est en train de se passer et
nous allons préparer la rentrée de
septembre avec ces principes là à
l'esprit et dans un esprit de
partenariat et de discussions avec tous
les acteurs
nous avons commencé déjà allé dans ce
sens et et vous le savez une mesure
exceptionnelle a été prise unique dans
les annales de l'éducation nationale qui
a été la création en cours d'année
civile il ya à peine trois semaines avec
l'accord du premier ministre et du
ministre des comptes publics de nouveaux
postes dans le premier degré je vous
rappelle que nous créions déjà plus de
400 postes dans le premier degré alors
qu'il ya moins d'élèves ya cinquante
mille élèves en moins nous y avons
ajouté plus de 1200 postes pour tenir
compte de la situation et notamment
financer les mesures que nous avons
indiqué c'est à dire pas de fermeture de
classe dans les communes rurales sans
l'accord du maire et amélioration du
taux d'encadrement dans toutes les
écoles primaires de toutes les communes
de france
là aussi en relation avec le maire qui
peut tout à fait vérifié
l'accomplissement de cette de cet
engagement
c'est unique dans les annales de
l'éducation nationale et ça doit nous
permettre certaines des choses que vous
avez dit notamment un encadrement plus
personnalisé et des mesures
de soutien scolaire d'accompagnement
individualisé de chaque enfant
ça c'est l'engagement que je prends pour
tenir compte d'éventuels retards liés à
la crise merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur hervé saulignac
monsieur le monsieur le premier ministre
chaque soir le directeur général de la
santé et graines triste bilan des
victimes du coronavirus en france mais
chaque soir le nombre de décès à
domicile et celui parmi les personnels
soignants constitue la statistique dont
on ne parle pas les chiffres annoncés
officiellement comptabilise uniquement
les décès enregistrés à l'hôpital et
partiellement dans les établissements
médico-sociaux pourtant l'insee nous
indique que la mortalité a tragiquement
progressé de près de 10% mois de mars et
que le nombre de décès à domicile
pourraient être considérables selon une
enquête réalisée par un syndicat de
médecins généralistes il pourrait
s'établir à 9000 autrement dit le nombre
de décès officiellement répertoriés
serait sous-estimer de 38%
s'agissant des personnels soignants là
aussi les interrogations demeurent des
médecins des infirmiers des aides
soignants et d'autres agents
hospitaliers qui ont perdu la vie passe
sous les radars de cette tragédie
et pourtant vous le savez toutes et tous
ils sont tombés pour la france
ce décompte funès n'a pas vocation à
alimenter l'inquiétude par des
statistiques morbide mais parce que nous
vivons un drame national sans précédent
l'ampleur de cette tragédie doit être
connu dans toutes les composantes de sa
réalité il en va de la transparence du
en nos concitoyens mais aussi de la
reconnaissance due aux familles des
victimes
cela me semble relever d'un principe
d'humanité essentiel passée la pandémie
les applaudissements donc se taire la
nation devra gravé dans le marbre le nom
de ses enfants qui ont perdu la vie le
président de la république a dit que
nous étions en guerre dans une guerre
rien n'est plus important que de pouvoir
estimer la réalité des pertes humaines
et d'en rendre compte à la nation
aucun soldat aucun civil qui perd la vie
dans un conflit armé ne peut se trouver
plongé dans les oubliettes de l'histoire
alors monsieur le premier ministre
combien parmi les premières lignes que
constituent les personnels soignants
auquel nous nous dirons jamais assez
notre reconnaissance et combien parmi
les français anonymes décédé à domicile
si chaque collègue la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le député hervé saulignac merci
pour la question que vous venez de me
poser vous le savez nous faisons preuve
de la plus grande transparence depuis le
début dans notre faculté à annoncer le
nombre de décès de victimes du côté de
19 dans notre pays et nous le faisons
d'ailleurs nous sommes le seul pays à le
faire non seulement en annonçant les
décès hospitaliers mais également en
annonçant les décès comptabilisés dans
les ehpad
vous regarderez dans toutes les
classifications internationales si vous
êtes capable de me dire dans quel pays
européens il ya tant de deux décès en
ehpad vous ne trouverez pas ce chiffre
il y à un autre chiffre pour lequel ou
m'interpellait qui est le décompte du
nombre de personnes qui ont pu mourir
domicile ce chiffre là il est plus
compliqué à évaluer pourquoi 6 77%
désormais des certificats de décès si je
ne me trompe pas son électronique
un certain nombre d'entre eux
contiennent la définition précise de la
cause de la mort à savoir locaux vides
et le lieu du décès permettant d'avoir
des données c'est santé publique france
qui est chargée de colliger tout cela de
faire des estimations de nous faire des
remontées nous aurons cette réponse
monsieur le député au mois de juin
comme tous les pays d'ailleurs qu'ils
sont en mesure d'avoir un système de
décompte des décès au domicile non pas
parce qu'il y aurait quelques volonté de
cacher quoi que ce soit ça ne servirait
à rien et ça n'aurait aucun sens mais
parce que ça nécessite justement d'être
capable de traiter tous les certificats
de décès et d électronique et des noms
électronique et d'avoir des statistiques
par territoire qui fasse sens ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que nous avons reçu
une première alerte de la part de santé
publique francs sur une possible
surmortalité à domicile comme c'était
attendu qui ne serait d'ailleurs pas
forcément liés aux covit mais peut-être
à aux complications médicales de gens
qui ne sont pas allés consulter à
l'hôpital et c'est pour ça que je
rappelle sans arrêt que les gens qui
sont malades qui ont des maladies
chroniques et qui doivent bénéficier de
soins doivent aller consulter enfin vous
m'interrogez sur les soignants morts au
combat
c'est un drame national vous avez raison
l'identité de chacun ne peut être connue
en raison du secret médical
par contre je peux vous garantir que
nous portons une attention à chaque
situation humaine ainsi qu'à leur
famille et je pense que la nation aura
à le reconnaître en temps voulu merci
monsieur mu la parole est à monsieur
sylvain waserman brune question monsieur
cyrille isaac sibille je vous remercie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
la question de mon collègue cyrille
isaac sibille s'adressa aux ministres
donc des solidarités de la santé la
stratégie de confinement qui a été
présenté hier par le premier ministre
nous apparaît pragmatique et cohérente
elle s'appuie sur une analyse
territorialisée de l'évolution et de la
circulation du virus
nous approuvons cette approche
géographique elle laisse cependant un
certain nombre de questions pratiques en
suspens notamment celle de l'utilisation
des données numériques de santé les dns
comment la couleur rouge ou verte qui
identifiera la situation de chaque
département sera t-elle déterminer de
quelle manière s'effectuera la collecte
et la centralisation des données
territoriales relatives à la circulation
du virus par des données individuelles
essentiellement par les statistiques
récoltées par l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et des
personnalisations ans maladie formant
les brigades départementales mais aussi
par des données collectives agrégé celle
ci devrait nous permettre de mieux
connaître et mieux suivre cette épidémie
monsieur le ministre cette crise doit
être l'occasion ne s'appuyait
massivement sur ce trésor d'informations
que constituent les données numériques
de santé comment sera mobilisé le reste
de la table mis en place récemment
pouvez-vous pensez-vous généralisé sur
tout le territoire français le coc vie
d'homme mis en place par les hôpitaux de
paris l'interopérabilité des systèmes
d'information de nos hôpitaux
le permettra-t-il et soutiendra vous
soutiendrez vous l'application quotidien
as qui permet de connaître l'évolution
de l'épidémie commune par commune
nous avions beaucoup de retard en termes
de prévention et d'usagé des données de
santé en un mot cette crise nous
permettra t-elle d'accélérer notre
stratégie numérique de santé cette
question est évidemment d'autant plus
importante pour les départements les
plus touchés et j'ai une pensée
particulière notamment bien sûr pour les
départements du rhône et du bas-rhin où
cyril et moi sommes élus ou les
habitants sont profondément touchés
meurtri par le virus mais aussi
solidaire courageux et qui regarde vers
l'avenir
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député je voudrais peut-être
vous répondre par l'exemple
nous sommes le 12 mai imaginons que j'ai
de la fièvre des difficultés pour
respirer
j'alerte directement un médecin par
téléphone par visio en allant le voir en
appelant le 15
en lisant j'ai des symptômes
immédiatement il me dit vous avez des
symptômes évocateurs du coc vide il faut
que vous soyez tester là vous pouvez
aller vous faire tester je vais sur le
drive sur le parking d'un laboratoire ou
dans un laboratoire voir si je peux me
déplacer
quelqu'un vient chez moi pour me faire
le prélèvement à ce stade commence le
formidable défi numérique est devant
nous il faut que tout soit traçable le
lieu où je suis prélever donc le lieu de
résidence
mon identité mais de façon aussi à être
pouvoir être anonymisées plus tard tout
cela part dans une base de données mon
prélèvements par un laboratoire qui
traite qui fait la plateforme p serre
qui traite le prélèvement
imaginons qu'il soit positif alors il
faut immédiatement que soit renseigné le
système d'information sur le fait que je
sais que je suis positif
qu'immédiatement su système
d'information remonte à la cellule
dédiée et pilotées par l'assurance
maladie en lien avec les agences
régionales de santé capable de me
contacter
d'abord pour me dire vous êtes vous est
positif vérifiez si j'ai besoin de soins
de quels soins j'ai besoin mais
également de pouvoir diligentée ensuite
une enquête avec ses fameuses brigades
dans le premier ministre a parlé hier
qui va s'assurer que mon entourage
proche peut bien être contactés que
toutes les personnes contactent
potentiellement malades désormais
peuvent être à nouveau contact etc
le chantier du système d'information a
démarré il ya plusieurs semaines en lien
avec cédric haut
il doit permettre de réaliser ce
formidable exploit qui fait que ce que
je sois l'hôpital dans un laboratoire où
dans un drive in fine et le système
d'information doit être unique et
permettent d'avoir des redescendre sur
les territoires pour pouvoir tracer
isoler efficacement les malades et par
ailleurs je salue avec vous un certain
nombre d'innovations comme à locaux
vides qui propose d'utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle pour
dépister précocement les symptômes de la
maladie on a besoin de cette innovation
numérique dans la période et je crois
qu'on peut saluer la force d'ingéniosité
nos ingénieurs de nos chercheurs et de
nos entrepreneurs
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur le président damien abad
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre les
français
jugeront sur la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle de votre plan présenté
hier à l'assemblée nationale sans masque
et ce en quantité de tests suffisante le
déconfinement sera partiel lent et
incertain le déconfinement sous
protection est le seul moyen de
maîtriser la deuxième vague est de
libérer notre économie dès dimanche les
républicains ont présenté un plan de
déconfinement claire territorialisée
sous protection autour de 50
propositions concrètes ont pu constater
hier dans votre déclaration que vous
avez retenu notre proposition de
déconfinement par département cette
approche par territoire est essentielle
malheureusement vous n'allez pas
jusqu'au bout de cette approche
à partir du moment où vous adoptez une
logique départementale pourquoi vous
refuser d'ouvrir les cafés et les
restaurants dès le 11 mai dans les
départements peu touchés par l'épidémie
par ailleurs pouvez vous nous dire
comment allez-vous mettre en oeuvre et
contrôler votre interdiction de
circulation au delà de 100 km sachant
que vous ne croisez pas le même nombre
de personnes dans un rayon de cent
kilomètres en lozère ou en ile de france
venant désormais aux protections
monsieur le premier ministre
nos hôpitaux et nos établissements
sanitaires manque de sur blues et de
médicaments quand et comment allez-vous
reconstituer ses stocks de matériel sur
les tests on a compris votre objectif de
700 mille tests mais vous continuez à
prétendre qu'il ne faut tester qu'en cas
d'apparition de cas symptomatiques
or vous le savez quand on sait que 50 %
des cas ce sont asymptomatiques et que
ce sont les asymptomatiques qui sont
responsables de 40 4% des contagions on
peut s'interroger sur cette stratégie
c'est tout simplement prendre le risque
de rater près de trois quarts des
clauses ternes et sans et d'avoir
toujours un coup de retard sur
l'épidémie monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous pouvoir tester par pcr à
partir du 11 mai toutes les personnes
dites confiné obligatoire c'est-à-dire
les résidents des ehpad des
établissements psychiatriques des
établissements pour personnes
handicapées où encore des prisons afin
de freiner les circuits de transmission
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président abadia plusieurs questions je
ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir répondre à
tous mais je voudrais revenir sur le
dernier aspect de votre question sur sur
les tests ce que j'ai indiqué hier ce
qui est important de bien comprendre
c'est que notre stratégie nationale de
tests qui est en effet calibré pour
qu'ils reposent sur 700 mille tests par
semaine doit nous permettre de tester de
façon systématique
toute personne déclarant des symptômes
et testé déclarent des symptômes elle
est testée
elle est positif si elle est positive
alors nous faisons exactement ce que
vient de dire le ministre des classes
des solidarités de la santé nous allons
remonter la chaîne des contacts de cette
personne positif et nous allons donc
tester
ceux qui sont entrés en contact
rapproché avec cette personne
symptomatique ou non la vérité c'est que
nous allons donc tester beaucoup d'à
symptomatique beaucoup de la
symptomatique tous ceux qui seront tous
les toutes les personnes qui sont
rentrés en contact rapproché avec
quelqu'un qui a été testé positif et
étant testé ça va donc faire beaucoup
d'à symptomatique nous considérons que
pour chaque cas nouveau set de l'ordre
de 20 à 25 pour prendre une petite marge
de sécurité monsieur le président abbas
nous avons compté jusqu'à 30 en moyenne
qu'à qui devront être testés
la somme de ces trente fois de ses 25 x
3000 fois cette donne environ 525 pitt
vous vérifierez mon calcul ça nous
laisse une marge pour avoir une
politique de tests spécifiques à
destination des publics les plus
fragiles et notamment des ehpad et c'est
dans le cadre de cette doctrine
nationale que nous allons mettre en
place ces tests mais votre question
offre la possibilité de dire assez
clairement que si pour des choix parfois
de réassurance parfois d'affichage on
sortait de cette doctrine de tests ont
commencé par exemple à tester de façon
absolument systématique une population
je ne sais pas moi par exemple 1000
salariés d'une autre
prise au sortir du confinement ça
n'aurait sur le plan de la santé
aucun intérêt vraiment je dis aucun
intérêt et s'ils s'étaient multipliés à
l'infini
ça rendrait impossible la politique
nationale de tests qui elle a une
logique qui elle est la seule qui permet
de casser les chaînes de transmission
donc nous avons le volume disponible
pour faire les tests dans le cadre de la
stratégie nationale nous allons même un
peu plus
heureusement pour avoir des politiques
spécifiques sur certains publics mais
j'insiste monsieur le président si nous
sortons de cette doctrine
si chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça marchera
pas au fond au fond tout le monde peut
comprendre ça si chacun fait ce qu'il
veut ça marchera pas et donc il faut
qu'on soit ensemble relativement
discipline et poursuivre cette doctrine
nationale qui a été exprimée clairement
qui va être mis en oeuvre par des
brigades par un ensemble d'acteurs
l'assurance maladie les agressent les
communes des départements s'associeront
peut-être s'il le souhaite on forcera
personne mais s'associeront peut-être à
ces brigades qui ont pour objectif de
remonter les chaînes de transmission et
de pouvoir les cas c'est parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on maîtrise une épiler vous
m'avez indiqué vous avez également posé
la question de la différenciation disant
que vous y étiez favorable je m'en
réjouis et moi aussi
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous mettons
en place mais vous avez indiqué que dans
le cadre de cette différenciation vous
auriez souhaité que dans chaque
département on puisse apprécier
peut-être le maire peut être le préfet
la possibilité d'ouvrir les cafés les
restaurants département par département
il se trouve monsieur le président à
battre que nous avons souhaitée et que
nous avons décidé que la réouverture des
cafés des restaurants sur l'ensemble du
territoire national serait déterminé le
31 mai pour avoir pour pouvoir entrer en
vigueur peut-être le 2 juin
pourquoi est ce que nous considérons que
c'est dans la prochaine marche qu'il
faudra se poser cette question parce que
nous voulons vérifier que les mesures
qui sont mises en place au moment du des
confirmands à partir du 11 mai
permettent de bien maîtriser la
circulation du virus est une approche
prudente et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé monsieur le
président à bad
vous avez hier dans une intervention
tout à fait remarquable indiqué que
gouverner c'est est décidée avant
d'ailleurs que la majorité de votre
groupe ne préfère s'abstenir
eh bien j'ai décidé
et c'est comme ça que ça se passe merci
monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur pascal brindeau
merci monsieur le président vous
écoutons monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez hier ici même devant la
représentation nationale développer les
mesures de déconfinement que le
gouvernement prévoit de mettre en oeuvre
à compter du 11 mai ce plan constitue
une nouvelle étape dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire qui frappe la france et
l'ensemble du monde depuis plusieurs
mois et qui vous a conduit à demander
aux français de se confiner depuis le 17
mai 17 mars dernier le principe du deal
confinement n'est pas en débat il faut
des confiné pour ne pas s'écrouler selon
vos propres termes
au plan économique et social vous avez
insisté sur le caractère progressif de
celui ci et son adaptation réalité
sanitaire différente d'un département à
l'autre en un mot sa territorialisation
je regrette avec mes collègues udi agir
et indépendant que vous n'alliez pas au
bout de cette logique de
territorialisation pour en faire une
stratégie réelle et qu'on construite
avec les collectivités territoriales
pourtant en première ligne dans la
gestion de la crise car si la situation
sanitaire de la nouvelle aquitaine n'est
pas celle du grand est si les mesures à
prendre sont évidemment différentes aux
sables d'olonne et à bobigny
comment comprendre que les plages
restent interdites à toute activité
quand les médiathèques peuvent réouvrir
partout en france
comment comprendre la réouverture des
écoles maternelles et élémentaires dès
le 11 mai certes sur la base du
volontariat
partout sur le territoire national et ne
pas le faire pour les collèges et lycées
dans les territoires peu ou pas touchés
pour le coc vide monsieur le premier
ministre pour que le déconfinement ne
soit pas un échec il faut la confiance
des français confiance dans la
crédibilité de la parole gouvernementale
confiance dans la cohérence du plan
annoncé confiance dans l'efficacité des
mesures annoncées confiance qui fait
encore défaut à ce jour alors monsieur
le premier ministre
pouvez-vous rassurer les français et
nous éclairer sur la cohérence de votre
plante déconfinement
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé monsieur le député brindeau
vous parlez de la confiance elle est
effectivement c'est un enjeu majeur
les français doivent pouvoir avoir
confiance parce que derrière cette
confiance est aussi le soutien de l'état
aux soignants le soutien de l'état aux
collectivités aux entreprises et puis
plus généralement aux français hier le
premier ministre a eu l'occasion de
présenter les grandes lignes du plan de
levée progressive du confinement à date
du 11 mai sur trois semaines
il a d'ailleurs eu la confiance de ce
parlement qui a amené à voter lui
accorder sa confiance à une large
majorité
je ne dis pas que ça peut lever tous les
questionnements et nous avons plusieurs
jours pour pouvoir répondre point par
point sur toutes les difficultés qui
pourraient être rencontrés çà et là mais
monsieur députés c'est un plan qui est
soumis à la concertation désormais aussi
des collectivités territoriales on parle
du binôme préfet maire les partenaires
sociaux sont concertés également les
associations d'usagers sont également
concertée cette concertation elle est
très large elle vit dans notre pays
c'est un un combat de la nation toute
entière que cette levée progressive du
confinement avec des possibilités qui
sont conférés aux territoires demain de
pouvoir en fonction de données
d'indicateurs que nous mettons à
disposition des collectivités et des
préfets de pouvoir déterminer sa hélas
il est nécessaire d'aller un peu plus
vite un peu plus lentement de revenir un
peu en arrière
cette flexibilité qui est accordée aux
collectivités c'était une demande
renouvelée répétées de la part des
collectivités des préfectures
c'est ce que nous avons d'ailleurs fait
lors du stade 2 de la maladie de
l'épidémie lorsqu'un certain nombre de
préfets ou de mer ont été amenés à
prendre des mesures territorialisée qui
pouvait aller d'ailleurs jusqu'à un
couvre-feu ou la suspension d'un certain
nombre de marchés ou d'activités en
journée dans leur commune
donc encore une fois cette trame ce plan
qui a été présenté qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale est maintenant à
la concertation des élus des préfets de
tous les acteurs de l'état pour qu'ils
puissent vivre
il sera à nouveau présenté dans sa
version finalisée et pourra vivre
ensuite dans les territoires au fur et à
mesure que ces territoires seront amenés
à
j'espère rester en verre ou basculer
d'une zone à une autre merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame sabine
rubin merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale je me fais le relais de
plusieurs interrogations et inquiétudes
de l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
plongez en plein désarroi après tant de
confusion et d'injonctions
contradictoires donc contre les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
la rentrée aura bien lieu le 11 mai
commençant par les plus jeunes élèves
maternelles et primaires soient ceux qui
peineront à respecter les barrières ceux
aussi qui ne peuvent se garder seul je
n'ose croire que cette décision est
motivée par la reprise de l'activité
économique
alors pourquoi retourner à l'école pour
faire quoi se demandent certains alors
qu'il ne restera qu'un peu plus d'un
mois d'école et si c'est par réel souci
de ne pas creuser les inégalités
certes exacerbée par cette crise alors
expliquez nous pourquoi son programme et
la suppression de classe où la baisse de
dotation pour la rentrée jusqu'en seine
saint denis département le plus favorise
défavorisés au lieu de muscler les
établissements en moyens humains
il faut aussi nous expliquer pourquoi
avoir décidé du volontariat qui laisse
les parents devant un choix cornélien
terriblement anxiogène anxiogène en plus
d'être inégalitaire car tout le monde
n'est pas à armes égales face au choix
d'emmener son enfant ou non à l'école et
d'ailleurs ce volontariat
n'est-il pas l'aveu d'une incertitude
sur l'efficacité des préconisations
sanitaires dont je sais vous venait de
préciser les termes et que répondre
alors aux enseignants pourront-ils être
volontaire eux aussi ou subiront-ils la
double peine de devoir assumer du
présentiel et dudit essentielle à la
fois enfin en cas de drame
qu'en sera-t-il de la responsabilité des
maires des chefs d'établissements des
directeurs voir des enseignants avec
dont la responsabilité pourrait être
engagée en fout enfin certains maires
ont déjà annoncé qu'ils n'ouvriraient
pas les écoles une grande partie de la
communauté éducative réclame la rentrée
de la rentrée en septembre comme le font
nos voisins italiens
et ce d'autant que de nouvelles études
alarme sur le risque de cas graves chez
les enfants monsieur le ministre
êtes vous prêts à réexaminer ce plan en
prenant en compte la parole de ceux qui
sont concernés
sur qui maintenant vous savez pouvoir
compter merci chers collègues la parole
est à monsieur jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés à ma députée
sabine haudepin je vous remercie pour
votre dernière phrase qui est
extrêmement exacte et qui doit être le
fondement de tout ce que je vais vous
répondre
autrement dit nous devons avoir une
unité nationale une unité au sein de
l'éducation nationale totale pour
franchir les différentes étapes qui sont
prévues maintenant en ayant en tête
d'ailleurs le plan de confinement le
plan de déconfinement maintenant les
vacances d'été et la préparation de la
rentrée de septembre dans une vision
commune qui est de bienveillance et par
exemple en matière de création de postes
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
de ce point de vue là je réfute que vous
avez dit nous créons des postes en
seine-saint-denis et dans le cas des
créations nouvelles nous en créons
encore et dans chaque commune de seine
saint denis
le taux d'encadrement sera meilleure que
l'année précédente donc de ce point de
vue là vous pouvez être rassurés
notre inspiration est d'abord sociale
l'exemple le plus fort c'est évidemment
les cp ce1 de repérer plus ils sont déjà
donc ils répondent par nature aux
conditions sanitaires qui sont fixés
sont des groupes de moins de 15 dont ils
font partie des premiers qui rentreront
et je m'en réjouis énormément parce que
oui notre priorité c'est l'école
primaire depuis trois ans c'est très
clair et ça l'est toujours plus est dans
une période comme ça c'est là qu'ils
allaient risque aussi de décrochage très
fort de décrochage de des apprentissages
et donc nous y tenons beaucoup
et toutes les mesures sont à l'avenant
c'est à dire avec cette préoccupation
sociale sur le volontariat des adultes
comme des élèves
je vous invite sur ce point comme sur
tous les points a résonné à contrario
c'est à dire êtes vous prête à soutenir
la thèse inverse et à la défendre
autrement dit ce que vous voulez que
nous allions chercher les élèves chez
eux et forcer les parents à les
accompagner
bien sûr que vous protestez auriez si
nous disions cela l'instruction est
obligatoire en france il n'y a aucun
doute sur ce point est ce qu a dit
président de la république qui
d'ailleurs correspond exactement à ce
que j'avais dit devant l'assemblée
nationale
quelques jours plus tôt était la seule
réponse possible c'est à dire oui
l'instruction est obligatoire
les parents ensuite envoi ou pas les
enfants à l'école s'il ne les envoie pas
il y aura enseignement à distance et
c'est ainsi que nous récupérerons les
quelques décrocheurs que nous avons
encore parce que nous serons
particulièrement attentifs à eux et nous
aurons évidemment une action pour les
inciter à venir donc louis la motivation
est profondément social elle est aussi
d'une
tu es nationale et j'espère que vous
suivrez aussi cet aspect merci monsieur
le ministre la parole est à monsieur
françois de rugy dans mes chers
collègues
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
présenté hier devant nous les mesures
d'accompagnement du déconfinement si
nous pouvons parler aujourd'hui de
déconfinement c'est que le confinement a
été efficace la courbe des
contaminations s'est inversée le pic de
l'épidémie est manifestement derrière
nous et ce résultat nous le devons au
civisme et à la responsabilité des
français
nous devons saluer cet effort des
français car c'est un effort c'est dur
pour beaucoup de nos compatriotes nous
le savons toutes et tous il faut saluer
ceux qui n'ont jamais arrêté de
travailler dans cette période pour que
les fonctions vitales du pays soit
assurée il faut aussi saluer ceux qui
ont déjà recommencé à travailler ou qui
vont le faire avant le 11 mai parce que
les conditions de sécurité sanitaires
sont réunies sans attendre le 11 mai
vous avez donc présenté ces mesures et
vous avez une phrase qui résume tout un
peu trop d'insouciance et l'épidémie
repart un peu trop de prudence et le
pays s'enfonce parmi les vois que vous
avez ouverte hier il y à la prise en
compte des différences territoriales des
différences de situation je suis bien
placé pour en parler je suis l'élu d'une
région les pays de la loire et l'ouest
de la france en général est heureusement
c'est une chance pour nous moins touché
que d'autres régions vous avez parlé
d'un classe d'un classement d'une
classification entre départements rouge
et département vert est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire quelles sont les
conséquences concrètes d'être dans un
département vert pour le déconfinement
pour les entreprises peut-être pour les
établissements scolaires écoles collèges
lycées pour l'ouverture des parcs et
jardins peut-être même des plages
comment comptez vous associez monsieur
le premier les élus locaux à ces mesures
différentes selon les territoires
merci sûr que l'aig la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
je m'associe d'abord à l'ensemble de ce
que vous avez évoqué au début de votre
question parce que en effet le
confinement a été pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens une épreuve d'effort au sens
où ils ont dû se priver eux mêmes par
leur propre civisme de visites qu'ils
aimé rendre d'une façon de vivre
laquelle il était attaché et que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux ça n'a pas été
simplement un renoncement à des choses
qu'on pourra remettre plus tard mais à
une véritable pression est quelque chose
qui aa probablement un coup et je ne
parle pas simplement du poids économique
un coût humain un coût social et donc je
m'associe évidemment à vos propos vous
vous posez la question de la
territorialisation un mot d'abord pour
rappeler cette logique entre ces
départements vert et ses départements
rouge
comment est-ce que nous allons classe et
un département en verre ou en rouge en
fonction d'indicateurs qui seront
évidemment publiques qui seront
actualisées tous les jours et qui
tiennent à trois logiques première
logique
le taux de cas nouveaux sur la
population c'est à dire au fond la
rapidité de circulation d'apparition de
nouveaux cas première batterie de
mesures deuxième batterie de mesures le
taux de préparation du système
hospitalier
la première vague a frappé les capacités
hospitalières partout ont été augmentés
s'agissant des lits de réanimation et de
soins intensifs
l'utilisation de ces lits intense de ces
lits de réanimation de soins intensifs a
été massive très au delà des capacités
normales d'occupation il faut voir si
région par région et c'est une approche
régionale pour le coup parce qu'on sait
que à l'intérieur d'une région les
capacités hospitalières sont souvent non
pas mutualiser
mais il est bien bien courant que dans
un département lorsque le cas est un peu
plus sévère en soit transférée vers à
sandra chu dont la zone de chalandise si
vous me permettez ce terme et régionales
bref la disponibilité la capacité du
système hospitalier à s'être remis de
cette première vague et puis troisième
indicateur la capacité des brigades que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
après la question du président abad a
remonté efficacement les chaînes de
transmission
ces trois grands indicateurs nous
permettent de savoir si dans un
département
le virus circule beaucoup ou peu et si
nous sommes en mesure de circonscrire
son évolution
département par département quels seront
les régimes différents qui s'attache au
classement en verre et au classement en
rouge
d'abord il ya un certain nombre
d'obligations est en vérité une majorité
d'obligations qui seront communes au
département vert et au département rouge
gelé indiqué il faut le répéter toutes
les mesures de distanciation sociales
toutes les de distanciation physique qui
vaut mieux arriver au mieux dire toutes
les mesures de précaution sont
évidemment commune à tous les
départements
ça va sans dire mais ça va mieux en le
disant toutes les méthodes
d'organisation les brigades de deux de
test de remonter des contacts tout cela
sera évidemment de la même nature
partout en france un certain nombre
d'obligations ou d'interdiction pardon
prévaudront partout en france
la capacité la nonne ouverture par
exemple des cafés et restaurants je les
dis restera valable partout en france au
moins jusqu'au 2 juin la non la nonne
ouverture des très grands centres
commerciaux restera valable partout en
france pourquoi parce que dans ces
grands centres commerciaux qui ont une
zone de chalandise qui celle qui va très
au delà du bassin de vie ont créé des
brassages ont fait venir des gens de
loin pour qu'il vienne ici et pour qu'il
reparte et cette logique de brassage
massif c'est évidemment ce contre quoi
nous voulons lutter dans la phase de
maîtrise de l'épidémie et donc ils
resteront fermés partout et ensuite sur
un certain nombre de choses
on peut évidemment différencier
l'application ce sera le cas s'agissant
du rythme d'ouvertures des écoles je
pense notamment au collège ce sera le
cas
aussi dans la façon dont nous aurons
quand je dis nous ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
les autorités préfectorales les
autorités de l'éducation nationale dans
les départements et les maires dont nous
apprécierons la discussion et je crois
que c'est très important de bien le
comprendre
dans un département vers l'ouverture des
écoles primaires elle peut se passer
alors bien sûr il ya des endroits où
elle va se passer de façon un peu
différente
il faut laisser le maire être en mesure
de dire aux responsables de l'éducation
nationale dans l'école anatole-france ça
va pas être la même chose que dans
l'école jean moulin
parce que les lieux la façon de
s'organiser
le nombre d'élèves inscrits dans l école
rendent plus facile ici que là
l'organisation parfaite de cette affaire
et ça c'est pas moi qui peux le dire
c'est pas le mini de l'éducation
nationale c'est souvent le directeur de
l'école le maire et le représentant
local de l'éducation nationale et j'ai
totalement confiance dans ces trois
acteurs si j'ose dire pour prendre les
bonnes décisions
donc il y aura des différenciations y
compris parfois l'interdît commune
après tout on peut l'accepter
l'important c'est que tout le monde
reprenne le chemin de l'école mais qu'on
prenne en compte la situation
particulière quand elle se présente à
l'intérieur même d'une commune quand on
sera dans une zone rouge donc ça c'était
pour les zones vertes et bleues quand on
sera dans une zone rouge et camer nous
dire à l'hôtel commune compte tenu de
l'explosion du nombre de cas on n'est
pas encore prêt et là on discutera avec
et on comprendra la spécificité de la
situation dans cette commune pour
essayer de trouver la bonne façon le bon
rythme d'ouvrir l'école dans les
départements en rouge
toutes les communes ne sont pas affectés
de la même façon et donc au fond ce que
je veux expliquer ici c'est que c'est
une logique qui commandent des effets et
qui commande
l'esprit du partenariat entre les élus
locaux et les acteurs de terrain
et je vais vous dire cet esprit il est
plus important à comprendre que la règle
parce que c'est celui qui va nous
permettre de piloter finement et
efficacement la maîtrise de la
circulation du virus donc il y aura des
départements vers des départements rouge
il y aura partout une discussion intense
précise confiante dans toute la mesure
du possible confiante pour prendre les
bonnes mesures
et je suis certain que face à ce risque
épidémique les acteurs locaux seront
adaptés les mesures au plus près de la
situation si monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à madame valérie base à
malgrat merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
alors que notre pays est confiné pour la
première fois de son histoire
les français dont le quotidien est
bouleversé ont souffert d'une
communication gouvernementale erratique
et contradictoires ce fut le cas pour la
question des masques celle des tests de
dépistage est désormais pour la question
scolaire qui est centrale pour la
reprise de notre pays
l'école est une institution qui fait la
fierté de notre république
mais son fonctionnement est aujourd'hui
profondément mise à mal les français
s'inquiètent des conditions du retour en
classe aussi deux tiers d'entre eux
refusent de remettre leurs enfants à
l'école et la confusion s'est installée
chez les enseignants avec les
républicains nous avons proposé
suivant l'exemple allemand le dépistage
de l'ensemble du corps enseignant et de
prendre la température de chaque élève
tous les jours afin de permettre une
reprise des cours dans les meilleures
conditions
votre gouvernement a fait le choix
étonnant d'écarter cette hypothèse vous
proposer à la place un retour sur la
base du volontariat en limitant à 15
élèves par classe ce qui renforce le
problème organisationnel
comment allez vous choisir ses quinze
élèves sur quels critères
comment allez vous éviter le décrochage
massif d'une génération toute entière
vous n'avez rien dit non plus sur l'aide
matérielle qui sera apporté aux communes
en particulier sur la mise à disposition
d'équipements de protection sur
l'organisation de la réponse est à sion
scolaire ni sur le transport scolaire
tous ces points doivent être éclaircis
de façon urgente
il reste moins de quinze jours et nous
maires ont besoin de savoir comment
rouvrir leur école en toute sécurité
comment expliquer également que les
lycéens soient les derniers à reprendre
les cours
alors que les classes de première
doivent passer le bac français en
présentiel et qu'ils n'ont aucune date
d'examen pour le moment alors monsieur
le ministre
allez vous proposer un plan de reprise
des cours claires opérationnelles sous
protection maintenant je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée bazin m'a grâce ce qui est
constructif est intéressant dans ce que
vous avez dit c'est le fait que vous
avez fait un plan de déconfinement mais
qu'il faut le regarder je les regardais
et je pense qu'on peut certainement
retenir des choses dans ce que vous avez
vu vous avez parlé de confusion la
confusion il peut être aussi entretenu
quand il n'ya pas toujours de la bonne
foi dans l'opposition hier j'entendais
le président abad parler de la question
de l'obligation scolaire et je vous
dirai la même chose que madame rubin
tout à l'heure est ce que vous êtes pour
l'obligation scolaire qui consisterait à
forcer une famille a envoyé les enfants
lorsque vous avez dit ça monsieur le
président la bad
là le journaliste vous disais mais alors
comment vous faites et vous disais on va
rassurer les familles mais vous n'avez
pas de réponse concrète pour ce que vous
avancez donc la haine non ça ne conduira
pas à l'obligation
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on aille
chacun au bout de nos raisonnements en
responsabilité comme si vous étiez en
mesure d'exercer un jour des
responsabilités et à ce moment là on
pourra suivre des choses et dans votre
plan il ya certainement des choses à
suivre mais je vous invite à chaque fois
à raisonner a contrario par rapport aux
mesures du gouvernement
s'agissant du protocole sanitaire vous
avez un protocole sanitaire qui est
discuté avec les associations d'élus
nous étions avec le premier ministre en
train de discuter avec elle avant de
venir ici
ce protocole sanitaire sera disponible
sur le terrain dès cette fin de semaine
il est travaillé depuis des semaines
vous utilisez le mot confusion pour
entretenir la confusion en réalité il ya
du travail qui est fait et qui
maintenant va se voir de plus en plus il
est tout à fait normal de procéder par
étape nous avons fait ainsi
j'ai d'ailleurs fait le travail de
parler devant la commission pendant 2h30
précisément pour poser des hypothèses
pour recueillir vos propositions
les prendre en compte
que le premier ministre les intègre
ensuite dans son plan et que maintenant
nous rentrions dans les détails pour
pouvoir appliquer cela de manière
concrète et pragmatique il ya trois
choses qui vont trois cadres désormais
il ya un cadre sanitaire
il est très clair on travailler avec le
bureau veritas et c'est désormais le
point de repère de tout le monde
il y à un cadre d'accueil ce cadre
d'accueil le premier ministre vient d'en
dire le les éléments j'en ai parlé en
détail ce matin à la radio il ya donc
une sous une souplesse sur le terrain et
troisièmement un cadre pédagogique et là
aussi tout est cadré et permettra des
souplesses de terrain merci monsieur le
ministre la parole à monsieur alain
bruneel et merci monsieur président
pardon monsieur le ministre de la santé
une phrase que vous avez twitté le 5
avril dernier a principalement marqué
les esprits voulzy annonciez la
subvention des plans de restructuration
dans les hôpitaux en les renvoyant à la
grande consultation qui suivra cette
crise de l'espoir il y en avait aussi
lorsqu'en début de crise le prix dans la
république avait déclaré je le cite que
la santé n'avait pas de prix et souhaité
décliner un grand plan massif
d'investissements pour l'hôpital nous
promettant à toutes et à tous que le
jour d'après ne sera pas un retour au
jour d'avant monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas précisément le même ressenti
sur le terrain les premières lumières du
jour d'après ressemble fortement à celle
d'avant pendant que les soignants
jettent toutes leurs forces pour lutter
contre le coc u19 à l'hôpital de douai
au vinatier à lyon et dans do beaucoup
d'autres hôpitaux
on continue à construire les futurs
contrat de retour à l'équilibré
financier et on continue de fermer des
lits ou des services sous couvert d'une
meilleure mutualisation des forces en
période de crise continuer à agir de la
sorte comme si de rien n'était surtout
en cette période de crise sanitaire est
tout simplement inacceptable et
constitue un véritable véritable insulte
aux équipes soignantes
monsieur le ministre les batailles les
luttes menées par le personnel
hospitalier depuis de nombreux mois sont
toujours d'actualité la colère des
soignants est toujours là elle est juste
pour le moment occulté pour le par le
combat qu'il mène contre cette maladie
certes vous suspendez les plans de
retour à l'équilibré financier mais
monsieur le ministre des mots
un sens le groupe communiste vous
demande d'aller plus loin en les
annulant redonner immédiatement ces
structures des marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires lors des précédentes
interventions vous évoquiez des réponses
tout en appelant les différents plans de
votre prédécesseur vous souhaitez
poursuivre les concertations pour
construire l'hôpital de demain
la période actuelle est constituée des
landes solidarité de débrouillardise
basé principalement sur de l'aide
extérieure
après la crise il est plus qu urgent de
concrétiser l'action de l'état avec des
moyens humains et financiers pour
l'hôpital l'état a reprise certes 10
milliards de la dette des hôpitaux
il en reste demain 20 milliards le
demandons une reprise totale de la neige
cercles et annulerait deux fait le les
plans de restructuration merci merci la
parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député brunel d'abord vous
dire que les soignants dans les hôpitaux
n'ont pas seulement fait preuve de
débrouillardise ou d'appels à l'aide
extérieure ils ont fait preuve du génie
je pense qu'on peut le dire sisi de
génie monsieur vidal je le pense
sincèrement je je je conserve des
équipes de réanimation infirmiers et
aides soignants médecins de différents
hôpitaux par visioconférence pour qu'ils
me racontent leur quotidien au pic de
l'épidémie je peux vous dire c'est
extrêmement impressionnant et on lit la
fierté sur le visage masqué de ces
soignants et je crois que c'est de faire
cette fierté elle n'est ni femme ni
usurpée parce que quand vous êtes
capable d'augmenter fois deux ou par
trois lits de réanimation quand vous
avez un animateur qui dit moi à ma
fierté c'est que je n'ai jamais était
amené à un tube est un malade dans un
couloir quand une infirmière vous dis ma
fierté c'est que je n'ai jamais été
amené à débrancher un malade d'un
respirateur pour pouvoir brancher un
malade plus jeunes sur le respirateur
quand vous avez les dix équipes qui vous
disent on a eu très peur on a vraiment
eu très peur quand on voyait l'afflux
des malades 500 600 nouveaux patients en
réanimation chaque jour en france
et quand on a vu qu'on avait la
possibilité d'évacuer des patients par
hélico par train par bateau
quand on a vu cet élan incroyable des
soignants qui ont traversé la france
pour venir nous prêter main forte et
nous permettent de tenir dans les
réanimations je vous garantis que c'est
ça aujourd'hui dont il me parle mais je
ne néglige pas le sujet profond dont
vous parlez
et la perte de sens dans certains mais
certains évoquent dans l'exercice au
quotidien et l'enjeu qui est devant nous
d'être capable de reconnaître à sa juste
valeur la place d'aidés soignants de ces
indispensables dans notre société pour
ce qu'elle doit être dans notre pays
ce sujet là nous continuons de l'aborder
évidemment vous imaginez que dans la
période
les soignants d'autres difficultés et
d'autres priorités que de rentrer dans
des grandes consultations à des grandes
concertations mais ce moment viendra il
a eu la prime annoncée par le premier
ministre qui est accordée aux soignants
de nos hôpitaux
il y eut plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros qui ont été accordés aux
hôpitaux et c'est normal dans la période
et j'ai annoncé la suspension de tous
les plans de restructuration sur tout le
territoire monsieur brunel donc à chaque
fois à chaque fois que dans un
territoire se fait jour l'idée qu'on
puisse continuer une restructuration au
vinatier au grand test ou ailleurs je
suis là pour rappeler croyez moi et dire
on arrête par simon arrête tout on verra
plus tard comment les choses évolueront
en concertation avec les acteurs
soyez rassurés merci monsieur le
ministre que chacun dans ses questions
ses réponses veille à respecter le temps
imparti quai de deux minutes vous allez
donner l'exemple monsieur la chose vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues le déconfinement du 11 mai se
fera dans des conditions
particulièrement hasardeuse pour limiter
les contagions le port du masque doit
être généralisé est obligatoire dans les
lieux publics mais alors s'ils sont
obligatoires comme l'école ils doivent
être gratuits et disponibles pour tous
et c'est à l'état de le garantir
personne ne doit être empêché de se
protéger de protéger les siens de
protéger les autres de la contagion pour
des raisons financières
vous devez décrété la gratuité des
masques et organiser leur distribution
mais vous vous refusez à le faire
pourquoi parce qu emmanuel macron vous a
imposé une date de déconfinement
arbitraire et que vous courrez derrière
parce que vous ne réquisitionné pas les
filières textile que vous êtes incapable
de planifier la production parce que les
chaînes d'approvisionnement et de
distribution ne sont même pas encore
déterminé chaque ville pourra ou non
fournir des masques à ses habitants
inégalités terrible parce que vous
refusez de contrôler les prix je vous
cite pour ne pas freiner l'innovation
hier dans une pharmacie j'ai trouvé un
masque en tissu à 13 euros
belle innovation
le premier ministre a annoncé que les
masques serait obligatoire dans certains
cas mais sans garantir leur distribution
les 5 millions de masques lavable à
destination des plus démunis seront
insuffisants quand on compte plus de 9
millions de pauvres dans notre pays vous
créez donc une discrimination des plus
vulnérables
si le prix du masque empêche des
personnes de s'en procurer
elles seront affectées les plus touchés
seront les plus pauvres et les plus
vulnérables aux formes graves de la
maladie
ceux qui vivent dans des logements plus
petits plus peuplés insalubre qui vivent
dans des déserts médicaux à la campagne
ou à la ville on peut voir les ravages
que fait la pandémie en
seine-saint-denis pour s'en convaincre
l'épidémie continuera de se répandre le
déconfinement sera un échec et nous
devrons peut-être reconfirmer comme
l'allemagne s'apprête à le faire
monsieur le ministre ne permettait pas
que l'épidémie repartent donner à toutes
et à tous les moyens pour se protéger
contre la contamination décrété la
gratuité des masques pour l'ensemble de
la population organisé leur distribution
merci monsieur le show la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de l'affronter monsieur le
député la chose la vie de chacun d'entre
nous a évité de se transformer même si
c'est pour j'imagine un effet de tribune
et que vous le pensez sans doute pas
sincèrement en prédicateur l'apocalypse
en disant l'épidémie va reprendre var
confiner le pays croient que les
français c'est pas le message qu'ils
attendent de la représentation nationale
aujourd'hui les français ils ont besoin
qu'on leur explique les mesures de
déconfinement où est ce qu'on va le
faire pourquoi nous le faisons dans
quels secteurs nous allons le faire et
quels sont les moyens qui leur sont
données et quels sont les moyens que eux
mêmes peuvent mettre en oeuvre pour
éviter une contamination et une nouvelle
augmentation de l'épidémie sur le
territoire ses moyens monsieur le député
lachaud
ce sont des gestes barrières on ne le
répétera jamais assez alors c'est
peut-être pas visible sa peur mais
peut-être pas d'aborder la question des
réquisitions et qui tiennent pas le
sabotage des mains mais il n'empêche que
ces mesures-là sont absolument
fondamentales
parmi les mesures parmi les dispositifs
en plus de la distanciation physique en
plus du lavage les mains en plus de
toutes ces mesures de ces mesures qui
fonctionne dans une épidémie à
qu'aujourd'hui qui fonctionne dans
toutes les épidémies
il y à l'équipement des français avec
des masques de protection des masques
grand public des masques normes et des
masques qui ne se fabrique pas de façon
extrêmement évidente des masques pour
lesquels il ya pas eu besoin de faire
une réquisition
il ya une mobilisation
général dans notre pays pour produire
ces masques plus d'une centaine
d'entreprises sont mobilisés nous avons
également des importations de ces
masques vous parler à juste titre ii du
risque d'inégalité sociale
le premier ministre a annoncé hier sur
cette tribune qu'il y aurait 5 millions
de masques des premiers stocks qui
serait donnée aux préfets aux
collectivités afin d'être donné par le
biais des ccs aux personnes en précarité
vous parlez de seine saint denis ça
tombe bien j'ai été samedi monsieur le
député lachaud
j'étais samedi en seine-saint-denis pour
rencontrer l'ensemble des associations
qui sont mobilisés dans le cas d'une
maison associative et qui nous ont dit
l'effort extraordinaire qu'elle réalise
au quotidien cette capacité qu'ils ont
eu à s'organiser à travailler ensemble
pour apporter des moyens alimentaire
pour apporter des moyens financiers vous
avez ils m'ont dis aussi merci pour ce
que fait l'état parce que l'état avec le
l'aide exceptionnelle de solidarité qui
leur est versé à partir du 15 mai elle
leur apporte aussi un soutien financier
indispensable dans la période on a
encore une fois enfin évitons évitons
les excès on peut se parler autres
membres sur la sho que aq merci monsieur
le ministre la parole est à madame
emilie bolivar merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la santé monsieur le
ministre la confiance dans les décisions
prises par le gouvernement en temps de
crise sanitaire est absolument crucial
vous l'avez dit vous-même
or après les contradictions manifestes
sur la doctrine d'usagé des masques par
le grand public nous apprenons que sur
10000 respirateur commandé par vos soins
au coeur de la crise
8500 sont inadaptés à la réanimation des
cas qu vide alors que le président de la
république avait très largement
communiqué sur cette commande pour
rassurer les soignants et les français
au coeur de la crise toutes les
opérations médicales nécessitant un
accès éventuelle à la réanimation ont
été déprogrammés justement pour que la
très grande majorité de nos respirateur
soit dédié aux patients atteints du
coronavirus en ce sens cette décision de
commander une majorité de respirateurs
osiris 3 est totalement incompréhensible
si les sociétés savantes on vient
valider ce choix
ce choix s'est vraisemblablement sous la
pression du gouvernement et en précisant
que ces ventilateurs serait utilisée en
dernier recours car en effet
ils ne sont pas réglable et peuvent même
être nocif au delà de deux jours une
utilisation pour ses passions ma
question n'est pas de polémiquer sur le
coût d'une telle mesure monsieur le
ministre mais de comprendre pourquoi
vous avez décidé au coeur de la crise de
commandes et 85% de respirateurs
inadapté à ses passions quelles ont été
vos critères de choix
de deux choses l'une soit vous ne saviez
pas que c'est respirateur et est
inadaptée dans ce cas c'est une erreur
manifeste de votre part ce dont je doute
soit vous saviez qu'il était apte
inadaptée mais vous avez quand même
décidé de les commander
dans ce cas est-ce parce que vous
souhaitiez artificiellement rassurer
l'opinion publique en maquillant la
réalité de cette commande et c'est
inacceptable
ou bien avez-vous conclu un accord avec
le consortium d'entreprises qui
expliquerait cette décision pour le
moins étrange et dans ce cas nous sommes
en droit d'en connaître les raisons vous
l'avez dit la confiance des français
implique merci aux parents mangez vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
merci madame merci beaucoup même madame
la députée bonnivard pour cette question
donc 100% sans polémique
comme vous avez pris le soin de préciser
vous même moment où vous la poser
j'attends de voir les questions
polémiques franchement avec grande
impatience ce jeu franchement c'était
c'était avec tact et mesure et je vous
en remercie je crois dans la période ça
s'impose
je vois que vous posez vous poser une
question sur les vous poser une question
sur les respirateurs d'un bon niveau
moi j'ai opposé vous feriez pas les
mauvaises habitudes de jeu et rompre
quand il y avait moins de monde c'est
infiniment plus calme en est cryptée
vient les questions et bien les réponses
gardons de cette période de crise cet
enseignement fort utile vous avez la
parole je vais je vais vous poser une
autre question celle que vous auriez pu
me poser dans une autre situation malin
bonnivard monsieur le ministre la santé
comment expliquez vous que la france
n'est pas tout mis en oeuvre pour
commander des respirateurs pour protéger
les malades
comment expliquez vous que malgré le
fait d'avoir eu quatorze mille lits de
réanimation grâce à l'action déterminée
des soignants vous n'ayez eu que dix
mille respirateur et que 4000 chambres
se soient retrouvées sans respirateur
que dites-vous aux familles de ces
malades qui n'ont pas pu bénéficier d'un
respirateur voir voir variante
internationale
trouvez vous normal monsieur loomis
la santé que la france un pays comme la
france soit obligé de demander à ce
qu'on branche deux malades sur un même
respirateur c'est ça les questions que
vous m'auriez posé madame bonhivers donc
je vais dire est je vais vous dire
quelque chose très calmement
j'assume tous les procès qui me seront
faits en vous en avais trop fait pour la
santé des français
j'assumerai toujours cela malin
bonhivers parce qu'on n'en fait jamais
trop pour la santé des français jamais
trop vous parlez vous parler et vous me
donnez l'occasion de remercier vous
perdez vos pas vous me permettez de
remercier les l'incroyable mobilisation
des salariés d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises françaises qui nuitées
jour sont venues dans les usines pour
produire plus de 10000 respirateurs pour
aider la france à faire face
schneider electric je vais les cités air
liquide je vais les cités c'est la
recherche et l'innovation les
respirateurs osiris 3 pour vous répondre
sur le fond
madame la députée sont des respirateurs
léger dit de transport qu'on est capable
de brader sa d ailleurs été fait dans un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux c'est à dire
qu'on est capable d'améliorer pour
pouvoir ventilé effectivement des
malades hospitalisés
vous imaginez bien que toutes nos
décisions sont appuyés sur les
recommandations des blouses blanches et
que nous avons concerté pour cela les
sociétés de réanimation encore une fois
on peut être fier là pays la france est
un pays qui produit des respirateurs
c'est respirateur sont utiles ils
auraient pu l'être encore plus
en france heureusement nous n'avons pas
eu besoin de recourir à tous et
réversible savait très content qu'on
puisse échanger avec eux leur en prêter
voir leur randonnée demain
la parole est à monsieur gilles lurton
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
comme tous les français je salue
l'implication majeure des soignantes
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie de
coronavirus je me félicite de votre
choix de les récompenser par des primes
même si je reste convaincu que c'est sur
une revalorisation des salaires et des
statuts qu'il nous faut travailler mais
vous avez choisi de les récompenser en
fonction des départements ou des
services dans lesquelles exercent les
agents concernés 1500 euros pour les
services couvrent de plus des hôpitaux
référencé dans les départements les plus
touchés 1500 euros pour les services
comme il que 8 des 108 hôpitaux de
référence 500 euros pour les autres
services alors ma question est simple
qu'est-ce qu'un hôpital de référence ou
plutôt comment seront traités les agents
qui ont travaillé la drass air disco vie
de plus
l'hôpital qui n'est pas classée comme
intervenant en première zone
eux aussi ont accueilli de nombreux
patients gravement malades eux aussi se
sont donnés sans compter mettre sa
interne infirmiers agents de service
adjoint de blanchisserie du restaurant
ou de l'administration tous les services
supports en général toute une chaîne
humaine s'est mobilisée pour assurer les
meilleures chances aux malades et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils font pendant toute
l'année
qu'en sera-t-il des agents des unités de
soins de long de suite ou des ehpad qui
ont été confrontées à la maladie et qui
parfois eux mêmes sont tombés malades
qu'en sera-t-il des agents des autres
services
quand l'hôpital n'est pas référencé
comme est plus sûr d'autres termes et à
titre d'exemple le groupement
hospitalier de territoire saint malo
dinan fait-il partie des 108
établissements référencés
il a accueilli de nombreux patients
qu'aux vide et certaines équipes
soignantes et médicales ont participé au
transfert de la région parisienne vers
la bretagne en train sanitaire le
personnel a fait preuve d'une
exemplarité à toute épreuve
sera-t-il bénéficiaires de la prime
exceptionnelle
envisagez-vous enfin une revalorisation
des salaires et des conditions de
travail plus satisfaisante pour les
hôpitaux français
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier veyrat ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député gilles dur ton merci pour votre
question et votre engagement sincère et
de toujours pour les soignants à
l'hôpital mais également dans les ehpad
vous le savez il ya une prime qui a été
annoncée qui est accordée à l'ensemble
des soignants tous corps de métiers
confondus
j'ai eu à rassurer d'ailleurs les
internes la semaine dernière qu'ils
pensaient pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux parce qu'ils étaient en stage en
ambulatoire ne pas être concernées il y
a toujours été question que ces internes
là soit concerné et je sais que il a des
interrogations sur les corps de métiers
nous l'avons dit tous les corps de
métiers hospitaliers sont concernés par
la prime vous posez la question ensuite
de cette prime différenciés selon qu'on
est et est entre guillemets en première
ligne au front ou qu'on ait travaillé
dans les établissements de santé mais
moins confrontés aux risques du coc vide
ou moins confronté à tout l'effort qui a
pu être réalisée même si tout le monde a
participé c'est pourquoi il ya une prime
pour tout le monde
et la règle de majoration à 50% des
heures supplémentaires d'ailleurs
concerne tout le monde partout posées
notamment la question dans votre
circonscription de l'établissement de
saint malo mme vous le savez il ya une
liste de cent huit établissements qui
ont été répertoriés comme accueillant en
particulier des malades ducobu qui ont
organisé des unités dédiées spécifique
mais pour autant à côté de ces
établissements il ya un certain nombre
d'établissements hospitaliers qui ont
participé de fait à la lutte contre
l'épidémie
même s'ils font pas partie de la liste
des 108 et qui ont une action
remarquable parce que ils ont été plus
fortement mobilisé que ce qui était
attendu
les règles le texte réglementaire qui
est en cours de travail devrait sortir
d'ici la fin de cette semaine je vous
redis dans 32 départements les plus
touchés tout le monde recevra la prime à
son plus haut niveau dans les autres
départements
il ya une liste qui est proposé des deux
hôpitaux qui bénéficieront des mêmes
dispositifs en matière de valorisation
de l'effort et de primes
mais encore une fois nous regardons les
situations au cas par cas il m'est déjà
arrivé de transmettre à mon cabinet la
situation particulière d'un hôpital
nous regarderons celui de saint malo
comme nous regardons la situation
d'autres établissements de manière à
valoriser tout le monde mais encore une
fois votre à travers votre question et
la réponse c'est que tout le monde a
participé à cet effort remarquable et je
crois que n'ai même plus besoin de
préciser à quel point les français sont
fiers et reconnaissants vis-à-vis de
leurs soignants
merci merci monsieur mais si nous
poursuivons maintenant notre séance des
questions portant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
monsieur jean marc dolisi vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
transports j'associe mes collègues
lorien rossi et damien pichereau la
liberté de se déplacer constitue le
socle essentiel de nos libertés
individuelles nous percevons ici
l'ampleur du sacrifice nécessaire
consentis par les français après plus de
quarante jours de confinement
premier facteur d'émancipation la
mobilité est au coeur de la promesse
républicaine et à cet égard je veux une
nouvelle fois exprimé la reconnaissance
de la représentation nationale envers
les femmes et les hommes qui assurent la
continuité de notre système de transport
et de fret
nous permettent de tenir le premier
ministre a annoncé hier des mesures
fortes pour rétablir de façon encadrée
les déplacements reprise maximum de
l'offre de transport en commun au local
réduction au minimum des transport
longue distance et application des
mesures de distanciation cet objectif
constitue un défi majeur pour les
opérateurs de transport pour les
autorités organisatrices de la mobilité
ce défi il est colossal pour nos pme nos
entreprise familiale de transport qui
irriguent nos territoires
alors monsieur le ministre comment
l'état va-t-il accompagner ces acteurs
de la mobilité pour assurer une offre de
transports publics tout en permettant la
bonne application des gestes barrières
de quelle manière des solutions
alternatives telles que le vélo peuvent
être être encouragé enfin qu'elle sera
monsieur le ministre l'offre de mobilité
réelle au 11 mai en france
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole et à monsieur jean baptiste
djebbari secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jules et jim
d'abord merci pour les mots que vous
avez eue pour les salariés du secteur
des transports particulièrement
mobilisés depuis le premier jour où
cette crise au fond vous me permettez de
revenir sur les trois piliers qui
consiste en cas qui soutiennent notre
politique de déconfinement dans les
transports d'abord une politique qui
consiste à augmenter l'offre est donc
très prosaïquement à avoir le plus de
ram possible le plus de véhicules de
transport possibles pour y mettre un
nombre réduit de personnes ensuite
diminuer la demande diminue et la
demande pour éviter les phénomènes de
d'engorgement dans les transports
publics notamment aux heures de pointe
et cela suppose en lien avec les
entreprises de faciliter le recours
comme cela prévaut actuellement au
télétravail ou encore d'organiser
l'étalement des heures d'embauché et de
débauche dans les entreprises c'est un
travail compliqué mais qui est fait de
façon efficace par mes courriels par mes
collègues bruno le maire
émue elle punit copie enfin protéger
protéger évidemment les opérateurs de
transport s'est fait depuis
d'ailleurs le début de cette crise un
décret a été pris en ce sens par le
premier ministre protégez évidemment les
voyageurs
ça s'est fait au travers de
l'amélioration des procédures de
nettoyage de désinfection et évidemment
par le port obligatoire du masque qui
prévaudra à côté du 11 mai qui fera
l'objet de contrôles et le cas échéant
de sanctions vous l'avez dit certains
sujets sont plus complexes que d'autres
notamment la mise en oeuvre des gestes
barrières du respect de la distance
physique dans les transports en commun
nous menons un dialogue constant et
continue avec les collectivités nous
étions encore sous l'égide du premier
ministre avec eux à 9h ce matin et nous
disposerons le 11 mai d'une organisation
solide robuste sur le plan juridique et
qui satisfasse les besoins de transport
dans le plein respect de la doctrine
sanitaire a dicté par le gouvernement
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur julien dive
merci monsieur le président j'associe
dino cinieri à ma question monsieur le
premier ministre la période de
confinement sanitaire vient de rappeler
à tous une réalité simple que beaucoup
avaient oublié ce sont nos agriculteurs
qui nous nourrissent et ne garantissent
une réelle sécurité alimentaire si les
soignants les ambulanciers les
auxiliaires de vie tous ces héros du
quotidien sont en première ligne
c'est aussi grâce à nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs nos pêcheurs placé en seconde
ligne que le pays a pu tenir
et pourtant cela ne sont pas épargnés
par la crise sanitaire et économique
c'est le cas de la filière laitière qui
voit de nombreux débouchés se fermer
comme la baisse de consommation des
fromages aop mais aussi les
horticulteurs qui ont vu perdre 50 à 80
% de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
parce qu on les interdit encore de
vendre certains plans que la grande
distribution peut elle de son côté
vendre et ce ne sont que deux exemples
confié son alimentation à d'autres
étaient hier une erreur ce serait une
folie demain je veux que nous
reconstruisions notre souveraineté
alimentaire avec une stratégie à
l'échelle européenne
malgré ses intentions la loi et galim a
échoué sur la répartition de la valeur
et nous ne pouvons plus conduire ni les
producteurs ni les consommateurs dans le
mur cette course folle au caddie
toujours moins cher tu de paysans et
n'enrichit pas le citoyen l'alimentation
est une des clés pour répondre aux défis
qui se dressent
devant nous bien manger c'est la santé
pour tous bien produire c'est agir sur
l'environnement bien transformer ces
soutenir notre industrie c'est cela que
doit rappeler notre stratégie de
souveraineté alimentaire
nous sommes face à deux enjeux monsieur
le premier ministre
protéger nos filières et refaire de la
france une puissance alimentaire comment
allez-vous décliné dans nos territoires
et dans quel délai les mesures d'urgence
signée par la commission européenne
le second enjeu c'est celui de
l'accessibilité alimentaire le pouvoir
d'achat des français s'étiole les temps
seront durs
notre devoir est de ne pas faire de
l'alimentation un marqueur de classe
sociale
il faudra des décisions courageuses
renversé des logiques
je vous demanderais agir sur deux
propositions de relance économique et
social baisser la tva sur un panel de
références alimentaires nationales
réduire les charges des producteurs pour
qu'ils soient compétitifs
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
agnès pannier-runacher secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député dif
merci d'abord de cet hommage appuyé que
vous avez rendu à toute la filière
agricole les agriculteurs les pêcheurs
les horticulteurs l'aquaculture tous et
toutes ces personnes qui ont contribué à
nourrir le pays ces dernières semaines à
un moment où effectivement nous n'avions
pas l'aisance d'un porté autant de
marchandises que d'habitude et je crois
qu'ils ont montré par leur implication
par leur engagement que justement cette
souveraineté alimentaire nous l'avions
déjà qu'elle n'était pas à reconstruire
qu'elle n'était pas à rebâtir en
revanche vous avez raison il faut
maintenant les accompagner les
accompagner dans l'urgence d'abord et
c'est ce que nous faisons
je veux rappeler ici qu'en termes de
chômage partiel
c'est 17 % des salariés agricoles 34% de
l'industrie agroalimentaire 45 % des
salariés pêcheurs et de l'aquaculture
qui sont soutenus par des mesures de
chômage partiel preuve de notre
engagement aux côtés de cette filière je
vais également souligné le travail qui a
été fait pour obtenir de la commission
européenne un certain nombre de mesures
de mesure pour des marchés destiné à
soutenir les filières agricoles et
agroalimentaires et nous devons aller
plus loin sur l'horticulture et
sur la viticulture qui sont de filière
particulièrement impactés et puis sur la
souveraineté il faut reconstruire alors
oui il faut reconstruire en n'allant pas
nous l'avons mais il faut se prémunir
des importations dont nous sommes
dépendants je pense aux protéines
animales pour les hommes et pour les
animaux nous avons pourtant des filières
qui sont intéressantes ne serait ce que
dans l'innovation je pense à tout ce qui
est protéines pour au travers des
insectes par exemple que nous sommes un
des leaders européens
donc une fois l'innovation il faut
déployer les mesures que nous avons
obtenus au niveau de la commission
européenne est allé plus loin il faut
également réfléchir collectivement et ça
va être un des enjeux du pacte productif
sur lequel nous avions travaillé
redresser notre industrie
agroalimentaire je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre le polt
monsieur bertrand pancher
oui monsieur le premier ministre il ya
deux jours j'étais en vidéoconférence
avec une classe d'élèves d'un collège à
ligny en barrois dans ma commune
dans ma circonscription et ses élèves
ont posé une question très simple qu'est
ce qui vous anime dans la vie qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire pourquoi vous
battez ainsi je leur ai dit mon combat
qui m'a amené à faire de la politique
était d'abord la lutte contre les
injustices
la recherche de la dignité humaine et la
recherche aussi d'un développement enfin
humains équilibre économique social
environnemental je pense que ça lui est
le combat de tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde et je leur ai dit que
c'était je pense en période de crise
qu'il fallait vraiment se poser la
question pour prendre les bonnes
directions si c'est pas ce moment là on
ne fait jamais c'est la raison pour
laquelle hier j'ai tenu un discours
peut-être un petit peu rude à votre
endroit mais j'ai voulu y mettre
vraiment vraiment toutes mes tripes
toutes mes tripes c'est maintenant c'est
une vraiment maintenant qu'il faut
changer
alors tout doit changer y compris dans
les entreprises
nous allons notamment aider des
entreprises à se redresser des grandes
entreprises publiques et je voudrais
vraiment avoir la certitude que ces
entreprises vont également prendre leur
part à ce changement notre pays et notre
monde
nous allons mettre 7 milliards d'euros
en aide dans ces entreprises publiques
notamment air france c'est au moment où
air france d'ailleurs ou
trois lignes sur le territoire national
qui aurait pu être payante directement
en concurrence avec les lignes de chemin
de fer chercher un peu également
l'erreur dans ce domaine est-ce que vous
pouvez nous rassurer sur les
contreparties en termes d' aide à la dz
des contreparties pour ces entreprises
de façon à faire en sorte que ces
entreprises comme tous les autres
illustrent le monde de demain que nous
voulons tous porter ensemble
merci chers collègues l'apport le toit
madame agnès pannier inachevé secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député pencher merci
de mettre en relation effectivement
l'action d'urgence que nous menons
aujourd'hui et la projection que nous
anticipons dans le monde de demain celui
où il faudra continuer à accompagner la
transition écologique et énergétique et
la transition également numérique car ce
sont deux piliers absolument essentiel
pour transformer notre économie et pour
faire en sorte de se projeter dans un
monde plus soutenable économiquement et
probablement aussi plus juste
socialement qui sont les deux objectifs
qui nous anime
alors vous poser la question plus
spécifique des aides que nous apportons
aux entreprises je veux d'abord dire ici
que ces aides visent à empêcher des
millions de salariés de se retrouver au
chômage
elle vise à empêcher une crise sociale
majeure qui aurait un impact
y compris d'ailleurs sur la santé des
français à moyen terme comme lorsque
nous précipitons les gens dans la
pauvreté
c'est ça le premier sens des aides qui
seront apportées aux entreprises est
effectivement comme vous l'indiquez et
comme je m'y étais engagé pendant le
débat parlementaire puisque nous avons
déjà eu ce débat
s'agissant du des 20 milliards d'euros
qui sont consacrés aux casses qui sont
des investissements faits par l'état
dans des entreprises ou des
accompagnements oui à chaque fois nous
ferons en sorte d'avoir une trajectoire
écologique et énergétique comme nous
venons de le faire avec air france air
france est d'ores et déjà une entreprise
qui est suivi dans le portefeuille de l'
agence des participations de l'état
n'était pas difficile de travailler sur
cette trajectoire puisque nous y avions
anticipé ce sujet là avec les services
de la pe et effectivement c'est un des
enjeux pour cette entreprise
au-delà de l'aide immédiate dont elles
peuvent bénéficier de se projeter dans
un futur soutenable écologique
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame olga giverny merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
cette période que nous vivons est
difficile pour tous les français depuis
le début l'état est présent pour nous
protéger contre le virus
il est présent aussi pour anticiper et
répondre à ses conséquences
nous sommes ici dans cette assemblée
pour préparer l'avenir un avenir où nous
devrons apprendre à vivre avec le virus
avant de retrouver le cours d'une vie
normale à cette période de l'année de
nombreux français devraient être en
train de prévoir leurs vacances d'été
nous devrions inscrire nos enfants dans
des centres de loisirs nous devrions
organiser nos retrouvailles familiales
acheter les billets de train ou louer
des résidences saisonnières la période
estivale commence mi juin et dès le 4
juillet les enfants seront libres si
toutefois vous nous confirmer le
calendrier des vacances scolaires
les français ont le droit à cette
interruption annuel il faudra se changer
les idées s'offrir des loisirs
il faudra goûter un peu de liberté
retrouvée et je cite ici l'incertitude
qui pèse sur les restaurants les cafés
les hébergements hôteliers mais aussi
l'ouverture des plages qui seront te une
réponse à ce besoin d'évasion
certains de nos concitoyens pourront
s'organiser
d'autres auront plus de difficultés à
surmonter les contraintes du moment
notre responsabilité sera de trouver des
réponses à tous
monsieur le premier ministre pour y est
vous préciser quelles sont les premières
recommandations et le calendrier
envisagé par le gouvernement pour aider
les français à l'organisation de cette
période estivale
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole de toi monsieur jean-baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée olga j'hibernais rendez vous
est pris pour la fin mai afin de donner
des perspectives aux professionnels du
tourisme aux restaurateurs aux secteurs
des loisirs
en effet il était important et bien
comme le premier cela dit d'avoir ce
déconfinement progressif de s'assurer et
bien de l'évolution de l'épidémie dans
les 15-20 jours qui vont suivre cette
date du 11 mai rendez vous est pris donc
fin mai à ce moment là nous pourrons
donner des perspectives claires vous
avez raison elles sont importantes
ces perspectives parce que chacun doit
s'organiser les professionnels lorsqu'il
ya le besoin de recruter des saisonniers
de reconstituer des stocks mais leur
donner une date trop tôt aurait pu les
conduire à prendre des risques si
d'aventuré on avait dû revenir ensuite
sur ces dates
donc nous sommes à la tâche avec les
professionnels pour élaborer notamment
un certain nombre de protocoles
sanitaires puisque je crois que les
français lors ce qu'ils voudront
souffler voudront aussi être rassuré sur
les conditions d'accueil est très
clairement je crois que cette saison
estivale
il faut le dire et tout le monde le voit
elle ne sera pas comme les autres le
tourisme ne pourra reprendre que de
façon concentrique
dans un premier temps avec une clientèle
je dirais d'ultra proximité et on le
voit avec un certain nombre de sites qui
vont pouvoir ouvrir les petits musées
certains sites naturels parcs et jardins
dans les départements qui seront verts
ou le virus ne circule pas de façon
active mais donc ça va être dans un
premier temps le temps de l'ultra
proximité et puis petit à petit en
fonction naturellement de l'évolution du
virus et bien les décisions pourront
être prises pour élargir il faudra que
tout le monde puisse souffler et nous
travaillons vous ai fait des
propositions je le sais les
parlementaires de la majorité pour un
tourisme pour tous avec des mesures
permettant de renforcer les chèques
vacances permettant de faciliter le
déplacement de tous
merci monsieur
la parole est à monsieur pierre yves
bournazel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de la culture dans
la terrible crise sanitaire que nous
traversons le secteur culturel souffre
évidemment il n'est pas épargné les
entrepreneurs culturels
les artistes les auteurs les
intermittents sont aussi en grave
difficulté inquiet légitimement inquiet
de la situation de la culture et des
arts la culture et vous le savez mieux
que quiconque
une réponse majeure aux maux de notre
société face à la montée du nationalisme
face à la montée de la haine de l'autre
face au danger du séparatisme face au
terrible fracture sociale économique et
culturelle et parfois communautaire
la culture c'est la connaissance et la
connaissance c'est la tolérance et nous
en avons besoin dans notre société c'est
aussi la liberté et le bonheur de vivre
ensemble alors face à ces inquiétudes
aujourd'hui des réponses ont été amenés
le premier ministre hier a très
clairement dit que progressivement nous
pourrons peut-être à partir du 11 mai
réouvrir des petits musées des
librairies des médiathèques des
bibliothèques et il faudra les soutenir
c'est important mais il ya aussi les
festivals
y aller théâtre il ya les cabaret il ya
les salles de cinéma
quelle politique mener pour c'est acteur
majeur dans les mois qui viennent il
faut les éclairer notre modèle
d'exception culturelle et parfois
jalousé
c'est une chance c'est une opportunité
formidable pour le jour d'après alors
j'aurai trois questions très simples
quelles initiatives après les bonnes
mesures que vous avez déjà prises
comptez vous prendre pour les
entreprises du secteur culturel et les
protéger quelles mesures comptez-vous
prendre également pour les auteurs pour
les artistes qui sont fragilisés en
difficulté et dont nous avons tant
besoin
enfin monsieur le ministre quelles
mesures comptez-vous prendre en faveur
des intermittents indispensable à la
politique culturelle à nos arts qui ne
pourront pas réaliser leurs heures dans
les prochains mois il faut faciliter
évidemment et prolonger leur habilité
c'est un impératif absolu je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre de la
culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
députés mais si le député monsieur le
député
bournazel je ne peux reprendre que tous
les mots que vous avez eue sur
l'importance de la culture pour nos
compatriotes à la fois individuellement
et collectivement l'importance de la
culture dans ce confinement la culture a
aidé et aide toujours nos compatriotes à
tenir dans ce confinement et les aidera
pour rebondir après alors dès le départ
le gouvernement sous l'autorité du
premier ministre a souhaité que toutes
les mesures transversales qui bénéficie
à tous les secteurs puissent être
accessibles aux professionnels de la
culture à la fois bien évidemment les
prêts et garanties par l'état
le chômage partiel le fonds de
solidarité qui permet notamment aux
artistes auteurs de pouvoir bénéficier
d'un certain nombre d' aide
bref que tout ce qui était prévu pour
tous les secteurs soient aussi
accessible à la culture et puis nous
avons complété par un certain nombre de
dispositifs spécifiques portés par les
opérateurs du secteur de la culture le
ministère de la culture bien évidemment
dans sa diversité ses opérateurs le cnm
le cnc le cnl le clap et d'autres encore
qui tout de suite ont mis à disposition
des moyens pour permettre d'accompagner
en urgence ce secteur sinistré nous
restera deux grands points majeurs à
travailler en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales en lien avec
les entreprises les associations les
liens avec tous les acteurs et les
artistes de la culture de prévoir
progressivement le déconfinement le
premier guerre a effectivement fixé un
premier cadre il devra être
progressivement affiné et ensuite il y
aura l'accompagnement à la reprise et
l'accompagnement à leur relance de ce
secteur si important pour notre pays et
pour tous nos compatriotes
nous aurons donc l'occasion avec vous
ici à l'assemblée nationale au sénat
avec les tous les parlementaires les
collectivités territoriales de bâtir
ensemble les meilleurs dispositifs pour
répondre au besoin si important de ces
secteurs si stratégique pour notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
notamment la marguerite deprez audebert
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre j'associais ma question
collègue laurent garcia la presse adapte
à la transition numérique et se
transforme dans ses usages
jamais la résilience de ces acteurs n'a
été aussi importante
se sachant investi d'un rôle sociétal
primordial dans cette crise sanitaire
la plupart des titres notamment
d'information politique et générale les
ipg continue de paraître en format
papier souvent à perte mais les recettes
du numérique ne compense pas loin s'en
faut
la chute des revenus publicitaires
catastrophiques ces deux derniers mois
ni celle de la diffusion tout aussi
abyssal dans les points de vente
car le modèle économique des journaux et
magazines repose toujours principalement
sur un duo de vente espace exemplaires
celui ci doit être maintenu la presse
papier doit donc continuer à être
distribuées le 20 avril presstalis la
principale des deux coopératives
assurant ce service est déclarée en
cessation de paiement la messagerie est
confronté un déclin structurel de son
activité exacerbées par la crise
actuelle qui met aviv des fragilités et
des difficultés chroniques
insuffisamment traitée depuis 20 ans le
plan de restructuration avec le soutien
massif de l'état dans la société a
bénéficié il ya moins de deux ans n'a
pas n'a pas pu que les précédents porté
ses fruits le nécessaire hergies de
presstalis fait courir un risque de
déstabilisation à l'ensemble d'un
secteur déjà bien fragilisé du
publicitaire à l'imprimeur et à nos
marchands de journaux
toujours dans l'attenté d'un versements
relatifs à 2019 nous devons préserver la
richesse et la spécificité française que
sont la diversité de ses titres le
foisonnement des petits éditeurs
ils font partie de notre patrimoine
culturel et territoriales aujourd'hui
mise à mal
monsieur le ministre comment à l'époque
des fakes encore mieux soutenir la
presse écrite vital pour ce rôle
d'information d'éducation et de lien
social auprès des citoyens lecteurs
que pensez vous d'un crédit d'impôt pour
les annonceurs comment l'état peut-il
assurer la pérennité de la distribution
de la presse
comment protéger l'ensemble des acteurs
de cette filière qui a pour vocation de
transmettre les savoirs et qui est
essentiel à notre quotidien et à notre
démocratie merci chers collègues la
parole est un monsieur franck riester
ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée avec vous depuis plusieurs mois
le gouvernement travaille à
l'accompagnement d'un secteur en crise
quel secteur de la presse et plus
largement des médias nous avons voté la
transposition de la directive droits
d'auteur pour créer un droit voisin au
droit d'auteur pour contribuer au
renouvellement du modèle économique de
la presse
nous avons fait en sorte de réformer la
loi bichet qui régit la distribution de
la presse écrite en s'appuyant sur les
fondamentaux de cette loi qui permet
d'assurer le pluralisme de la presse
mais tout en le modernisant pour
permettre notamment que la régulation
soit plus efficiente
nous travaillons avec bruno le maire a
un plan de filières qui permettent de
regarder la totalité des problématiques
de cette filière est d'essayer d'y
apporter des réponses et nous
travaillons bien évidemment sur la
question spécifiquement de presstalis
qui traverse une crise depuis des années
et qui aujourd'hui a dû se déclarer en
cessation de paiement mais nous
travaillons avec les éditeurs de presse
avec les différentes coopératives avec
le ministère de l'économie des finances
et mystères de la culture a trouvé un
dispositif pérenne en lien avec l'arcep
qui permettent de garantir sur tout le
territoire le maintien d'une
distribution de la presse écrite par
tous assurant le pluralisme de la presse
avec une diversité des éditeurs de
presse c'est complexe c'est difficile
mais l'état à veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de rupture de la digue dans la
distribution de la presse et continuera
de le faire et continuera d'appuyer à ce
nouveau modèle qui est en train
d'inventer presstalis les éditeurs de
presse
pour le reste nous sommes toujours aussi
vigilant à ce qu'est la santé des
éditeurs notamment les plus dire que ce
soit dans l'hexagone ou en outre-mer
nous savons qu'il ya un certain nombre
de titres qui ont des difficultés on a
eu l'occasion de parler de france
antilles on peut penser appareils
normandie il ya des titres à la réunion
aussi qui sont très fragiles et dans
bien d'autres endroits
nous continuerons avec ses titres avec
les organisations professionnelles à
trouver des solutions pour chacun car
c'est la diversité de la presse garantie
sont plurielles son pluralisme merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole était madame george pau
langevin merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
culture également et j'y associe mes
collègues michel victory et sylvie à
tout le monde mais chaque collègue la
terrible crise que notre nation traverse
actuellement affecte tous les secteurs
d'activité de notre pays mais
effectivement le monde de la culture
sera ed plus dramatiquement et plus
durablement affecté la fermeture des
cafés théâtres et autres lieux culturels
l'annulation de festival va impacter
durablement les revenus des artistes
souvent déjà en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
les intermittents du spectacle risque de
ne pas obtenir le renouvellement de leur
statut le secteur du spectacle vivant
qui est à l'arrêt perdrait du 1er mars
au 31 mai
590 millions d'euros l'inquiétude
grandit également du côté des
institutions culturelles l'ordonance du
22 avril 2020 a certes apporté des
modifications nécessaires aux
dispositifs de chômage partiel mais dans
des conditions encore drastiques pour
les établissements publics et les cem
qui pour en bénéficier doivent tirer la
majorité de leurs ressources d'une
activité industrielle et commerciale
comme la location des espaces ce qui est
rarement le cas des établissements de
qualité comme le 104 ou la gaîté lyrique
voir la philharmonie sont donc menacés
les collectivités locales ne peuvent
assumer des montants aussi élevés
alors qu'elle leur accorde déjà des
subventions publiques les plus petites
associations pour le chômage partiel
peinent à avancer les salaires et la
partie de charges non remboursable en
cette période d'inactivité
monsieur le ministre les emplois de ce
secteur déjà fragiles sont
indispensables à la vie économique de
notre pays et contribuer à son
rayonnement ainsi que vivre ensemble
dans notre société
quels sont vos réponses pour la
sauvegarde des emplois du secteur
culturel avec votre collègue madame
pénicaud pensez-vous assouplir les
conditions d'accès au chômage partiel
pour les épiques et les structures
subventionnées
merci chers collègues la pole
est un monsieur franck riester ministre
de la culture
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée comme je lé rappeler tout à
l'heure en répondant à monsieur
bournazel le gouvernement a fait en
sorte que les mesures transversales
puisse être accessible aux
professionnels de la culture est
spécifiquement pour l'accès au chômage
partiel puisque les entreprises de la
culture peuvent eux aussi avoir accès
elle aussi avoir accès au chômage
partiel
et c'est notamment aussi le cas pour
l'intermittence intermittence qui avait
que muriel pénicaud nous avons fait
évoluer dont nous avons fait évoluer les
règles d'accès pour tenir compte du
confinement et que les droits puissent
être maintenus pour un certain nombre
d'intermittents qui sans cette décision
étant donné qu'il ne pouvait pas
réaliser leur spectacle où leurs heures
pendant la période de confinement
auraient été exclus des dispositifs de
l'intermittence nous avons aussi bien
évidemment fait en sorte de permettre
que à travers un fonds professionnels
qui est en cours de réalisation ce
qu'ils sont or le processus de
d'intermittence puissent bénéficier des
aides sociales pour que personne ne soit
mis sur le bord de la route
nous travaillons aussi avec muriel
pénicaud à l'avenir parce qu on comprend
bien que les dispositions d'urgence qui
ont été prises ne seront pas suffisantes
sur le temps long et que la crise dans
la culture malheureusement va durer
longtemps et donc nécessaire de pouvoir
donner de la visibilité aux
intermittents dans leurs statuts et
l'accès à leurs droits sociaux ensuite
nous avons travaillé spécifiquement par
ensuite institutions les entreprises
sont elles ont accès au chômage partiel
les associations comptent accès au
chômage partiel les épiques ont accès au
chômage partiel s'ils ont des
financements publics minoritaires voilà
c'est la règle et nous travaillons à ce
que les opc sais quel que soit leur mode
de financement
leur proportion de financements privés
ou publics puissent bénéficier aussi de
l'accès au chômage partiel nous y
travaillons techno politiquement la
décision a été prise il reste maintenant
techniquement à la mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir que ces institutions elle aussi
puissent avoir accès au chômage partiel
mais bien évidemment
d'une façon plus large il faudra
regarder les moyens mis au service de
ses réseaux exceptionnels notamment dans
le spectacle vivant qui assure des
spectacles exceptionnels pour nos
compatriotes
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
notamment d'hommes le tissu oeuvre merci
monsieur le président à ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de la justice
gs aussi l'ensemble de mes collègues
commissaires aux lois de la république
en marche
madame la ministre nous tenons tout
d'abord à saluer les mesures prises pour
limiter la propagation du virus dans
l'univers carcéral et à rendre hommage
au personnel pénitentiaire pour son
professionnalisme et son dévouement dans
cette période difficile
madame la ministre nous avons été
alertés par les conditions dans
lesquelles de nombreux prévenus ont vu
leur détention provisoire prolongée
automatiquement sans passer devant un
juge sans être assisté d'un avocat
de telles procédures ne peuvent perdurer
y compris en état d'urgence sanitaire
c'est pourquoi nous nous associons aux
demandes formulées afin que cette mesure
exceptionnelle prenne fin dès le
déconfinement du 11 mai et que les
prévenus puissent rapidement être
présenté devant un juge des libertés et
de la détention
nous savons que vous avez pris des
engagements en ce sens que nous allions
est encourageant mais au delà de la
prolongation des détentions provisoires
se pose la question des demandes de
remise en liberté des prévenus en cette
période de restriction de limitation des
déplacements
le formalisme actuel est trop lourd et
inadaptée à la période que nous
connaissons c'est pourquoi nous
proposons que les demandes de remise en
liberté puissent être transmises par
email lorsque les conditions de leur
examen le permettent
par exemple quand il s'agit de
transmettre des justificatifs de
domicile ou de travail aux fins de
garanties de représentation du prévenu
enfin parce qu'il faut donner tout son
sens à la détention provisoire
celui de faire avancer l'enquêté est ce
plus encore pour ceux dans la détention
a été prolongée sans qu'un juge ne
réexamine leur dossier nous souhaitons
que tous ces prévenus puisse présenter
leurs éléments de défense de fond avec
leurs avocats devant le juge
d'instruction avant la fin de la
détention provisoire voici madame la
ministre les propositions que nous vous
soumettons des propositions qui doivent
s'inscrire
dans un plan de reprise de l'activité
judiciaire que nous appelons de nos
voeux pour la préservation des droits
des justiciables
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
députés messieurs les députés madame la
députée avia je m'associe tout d'abord
aux remerciements vous avez adressé au
personnel de l'administration
pénitentiaire
de même que je veux d'ailleurs devant
vous souligner l'engagement de
l'ensemble des personnels de justice
dans cette période difficile du fait de
la pandémie nos juridictions nos
tribunaux ont dû se réorganiser et
notamment la tenue des audiences s'est
avérée particulièrement complexe et
certains magistrats vous le savez pour
des raisons diverses ont été empêchés
c'est la raison pour laquelle le respect
des délais légaux et notamment les
délais de détention provisoire s'est
avéré parfois difficiles voire
impossibles
il était donc de ma responsabilité
d'éviter que des personnes présumées
dangereuses puisse de ce fait être
libérés je rappelle ici que sur 15000
personnes actuellement en détention
provisoire près des deux tiers le sont
du fait d' instructions pour des faits
de nature criminelle
c'est l'objet de l' ordonnance du 25
mars mais il est aussi et j'insiste
beaucoup là dessus de ma responsabilité
de faire en sorte que le retour au droit
commun s'effectue le plus tôt possible
le retour progressif à une situation
normale commençant à partir du 11 mai je
vais donc présenté aujourd'hui au
conseil d'état un projet d'ordonnancé
permettant le retour aux dispositions du
code de procédure pénale un retour
évidemment dans des conditions adaptées
je prends note madame la députée d'un
certain nombre de vos propositions qui
visent à faciliter la l'examen des
demandes de mise en liberté est
également de permettre au juge
d'instruction de pouvoir réinterroger
une personne prévenue dans les deux
moi si celle ci a fait l'objet d'une
prolongation de plein droit de sa
détention provisoire
vos propositions correspondent
parfaitement à ma volonté d'un réexamen
rapide des situations des personnes qui
n'ont pas pu être traités pendant la
période de confinement vos propositions
donc madame la députée sont des pistes
très intéressantes et je vous en
remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame mode petit monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre jacqueline gourault dans la
crise que traverse aujourd'hui le monde
entier l'unité la solidarité nous
sauverons au nom de ces principes je
souhaite réaffirmer ici l'évidence cette
situation inédite ne peut se résoudre
sans le support de nos collectivités
locales véritables garanties de la vie
de nos territoires les communes sont une
fois de plus en première ligne ce sont
nos mères qui sont à portée de sourires
et de baffes
quand nos concitoyens s'interrogent et
s'inquiètent ce sont nos aînés de
proximité qui dans les villages se
mobilise souvent personnellement pour
apporter soutien et aide aux personnes
les plus isolées et les plus fragiles
ce sera à eux aussi qu'incombera la
déclinaison locale des mesures prises
par l'état pour le déconfinement
exprimant leur toute notre
reconnaissance pour ses engagements
permanents mais la gratitude ne suffira
pas cette crise engendrera de lourdes
conséquences sur les budgets et
l'organisation de nos communes et les
élus nos alertes
certes le confinement a engendré
quelques baisses de dépenses mais elle
ne compenseront pas le déficit à prévoir
par le manque de recettes lié aux
annulations de manifestations ni celui
causé par les dépenses supplémentaires
liées à la crise sanitaire achats de
masques remise en état réouverture et
entretien des infrastructures
municipales achats de produits
sanitaires pour la rentrée scolaire est
en crèche réorganisation rh du
périscolaire maintien des subventions
aux associations recrutement de
personnel supplémentaire pôle isa sion
cassation culturelles et sportives bref
la déclinaison et la responsabilité du
déconfinement seront partagés entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
or compte tenu de la sur-sollicitation
de nos communes et les dépenses
exceptionnelles engagées par la crise
nous ne pouvons
les laisser risquer la faillite et notre
devoir est de les accompagner le
gouvernement doit assurer à nos élus
locaux qu'à l'issue de cette crise et ne
seront pas laissés pour compte
c'est pourquoi je vous demande madame la
ministre qu'un plan de soutien
spécifique aux municipalités puissent
être envisagés
c'est une exigence sinéquanone au
principe de solidarité indispensable à
l'état de santé de nos territoires et
donc de notre pays je vous en remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le président madame la
député mohd petit je vous remercie pour
votre question qui me permet de faire le
point sur les mesures déjà engagées pour
soutenir les collectivités locales ainsi
que les pistes sur lesquelles nous
travaillons aujourd'hui il y a quelques
semaines l'urgence était d'éviter que
les communes ne se trouve en difficulté
temporaire de trésorerie enfin pour
certaines et ne puisse donc pas honorer
leurs factures ou payer leurs agents
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pris des mesures immédiates en
assouplissant les conditions sur
lesquelles les communes peuvent tirer
sur les lignes de trésorerie ouverte
auprès des banques notamment en
autorisant les maires à le faire
directement et en demandant aux préfets
de mobiliser les avances de fiscalité ou
de dotation dont auraient besoin
les collectivités territoriales je crois
que cela était utile sera utile encore
car nous continuerons à le faire aucune
commune n'est aujourd'hui en rupture de
paiement
aujourd'hui l'urgence que vous l'avez
rappelé est de permettre aux
collectivités territoriales de faire
face au coût de mise en oeuvre du plan
de déconfinement et je peux vous assurer
ici et je le dis haut et fort que ces
dépenses seront évalués ces coûts seront
évalués et nous travaillons déjà avec le
ministre du budget des comptes publics
et mon ministère pour envisager des
réponses pratiques si je puis dire à ses
dépends ccir sur coup des dépenses
prenons un exemple peut-être les masques
vous le savez les collectivités sont
incités à fournir à se fournir en masque
pour réussir le rendez vous du 11 mai
le jeu ne revient pas mais ce qui a été
important c'est l'annoncé du premier
ministre hier dans cet hémicycle pour la
participation bien sûr de l'état d'un 50
% du coût des masques grand public
acquis par les collectivités locales
j'avais répondu d'ailleurs la semaine
dernière à une question de monsieur le
coq sur le sujet des dépenses et j'avais
dit que nous ne laisserions pas tomber
les collectivités locales nous ne
laissons pas tomber ces collectivités
locales y compris quand elle monte de
recettes
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean marie sermier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
dans le plan de déconfinement que vous
avez présenté hier les élus locaux
occupent une place majeure en première
ligne depuis le début de la crise
il travaille pourtant dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles dans
trente mille des 35000 communes
françaises
les équipes élu dès le premier tour le
15 mars dernier n'ont toujours pas été
installés dans les 5000 autres communes
les maires sortants assument leurs
fonctions sans visibilité sur
l'organisation du second tour ce qui est
forcément inconfortable or
l'installation des conseils municipaux
est indispensable à la relance de la
commande publique qui constitue un
levier essentiel du redémarrage de
l'économie
vous n'avez pas parlé hier de tout cela
qu'on pourront enfin être installée les
nouvelles équipes municipales
malgré ces incertitudes monsieur le
premier ministre les maires sont sur
tous les fronts
la commande et la distribution des
masques pour la population
la coordination des initiatives
citoyennes pour la fabrication des
matériels de protection la mise en
sécurité sanitaire des écoles des
crèches des centres de loisirs
l'adaptation dès réseaux de transports
publics aux règles de distanciation la
gestion des marchés la réouverture des
déchetteries qui sont un service public
indispensable
les élus locaux connaissent mieux que
quiconque les contraintes propres à leur
territoire depuis le début de la crise
il
preuve d'un grand sens de responsabilité
et souvent même de courage nous
souhaitons qu'ils aient une grande marge
de manoeuvre dans l'organisation du
coude et confinement cela suppose pour
les administrations telles que la dréal
les directs les ars qu'elles soient
souples et bienveillante à leur endroit
monsieur le premier ministre le
pragmatisme et le bon sens ce sont les
maîtres mots de la réussite du
déconfinement allez vous laisser
suffisamment de souplesse aux élus
locaux
allez-vous passer des consignes claires
à vos administrations merci monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je veux dire que je
pourrai reprendre je crois mot pour mot
la déclaration voudrais tu faire avant
la question que vous posez à la fois
dans la reconnaissance du rôle qu'ont
joué dans des circonstances délicates
comme celle que nous connaissons avec
cette crise sanitaire comme il rejoue
toujours les élus locaux et aux premiers
rangs desquels évidemment les maires
dans la nécessité pour la construction
et la mise en oeuvre de ce plan national
de déconfinement de faire confiance et
de travailler intelligemment faire
confiance à veut pas dire oui
systématiquement ça veut dire pouvoir
travailler intelligemment en comprenant
bien l'objectif commun et en essayant
trouver les meilleures solutions à
plusieurs pour l'atteindre
donc vraiment je suis complètement sur
la ligne que vous venez de décrire
vous avez attiré l'attention du
gouvernement vous posez la question
premier ministre de savoir quand les
conseils municipaux qui ont été
complètement élu au terme de l'élection
qui s'est tenue le 15 mars pourront être
installés et on comprend à la fois
l'impatience légitime le souci de clarté
il est nécessaire pour des équipes élues
mais qui ne peuvent pas entrer en
fonction et peut-être encore plus pour
des équipes parfois battus ou ayant
parfois renoncer à se présenter et qui
doivent assurer la gestion des affaires
de la commune après soit une élection
soit une défaite ça n'est pas non plus
d'une très grande simplicité et d'une
certaine façon je pense à eux aussi
parce
ils doivent faire face à des
responsabilités qui sont importantes je
les dis hier en réponse aux
interventions des différents orateurs
je le redis ce matin bien volontiers
notre objectif c'est que les conseils
municipaux qui ont été élus dans leur
totalité
le premier euro au soir du premier tour
puis s'être installé le plus rapidement
possible est vraiment le plus rapidement
possible et pas de double langage ya pas
de plus vite ils seront installés plus
les choses seront claires sur ces 30 sur
ses trente mille communes
l'immense majorité d'entre elles qui se
trouve dans la situation que vous
décrivez est composé de conseils
municipaux à quinze membres
je ne me paraît mais je suis prudent car
vous savez qu'une procédure a été prévu
par la loi qui veut qu'un rapport puisse
dire au 11 mai si nous serons capables
d'installer les conseils municipaux je
ne veux donc pas aller plus vite que la
musique
mais il me paraît que dès lors qu'on dès
lors qu'on des confine le 11 mai et on
doit pouvoir réunir dans un cadre donc
j'ai bon espoir que nous puissions le
faire le plus rapidement possible je
pense que c'est une bonne chose à la
fois pour la clarté de l'action
politique et de la vie politique aussi
probablement pour que des décisions
puissent être prises conformément à des
engagements qui ont été passés les
décisions d'investissement des décisions
administratives des décisions qui
parfois conduisent à des projets locaux
bref je pense qu'il est utile que cette
installation puisse avoir lieu alors a
lieu dans les plus brefs délais mais
dans le respect vous le comprendrez bien
dans le respect de la procédure que nous
avons convenu ensemble et qui a été voté
par le parlement
merci monsieur le premier ministre à
paroles de monsieur françois jolivet
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre auprès de la ministre des
armées
la crise sanitaire mais notre pays à
l'épreuve bouscule notre quotidien ils
nous touchent parfois dans sa dimension
intime la plus douloureuse
les victimes sont nombreuses et des
familles sont endeuillées
cette épidémie construit des peines qui
forment un drame national pour que notre
pays continue à vivre et qu'il puisse
soigner des françaises et des français
sont en première ligne
ils sont au travail mène un combat au
profit de leurs semblables les met en
danger plus que d'autres leur propre
santé ces visages s'est engagé au
service des autres c'est applaudi de 20h
sont aussi parfois des mères et des
pères de famille dans l'indre à
châteauroux
une aide soignante veuve de 48 ans est
décédé et laisse dans son sillage quatre
orphelins
je veux lui rendre hommage je veux
adresser toutes mes pensées à ses
enfants
toutes nos pensées avec 40 de mes
collègues nous avons récemment appelé à
la création d'un statut de
reconnaissance nationale semblable à
celui de pupille de la nation
destiné à aider des enfants ayant perdu
un parent durant la guerre contre le coc
vide 19
l'objectif est de rendre possible pour
ces derniers la construction d'un avenir
plus apaisé même si la perte d'un parent
ne saurait être réparées après la
diffusion de cette idée par la presse
que je remercie beaucoup de personnes
qui oeuvrent dans le domaine notamment
médicales sont venus vers moi
tous y sont très favorables je
retiendrai une réflexion d'une
infirmière qui m'a dit je cite si ça
existait on s'inquiéterait moins pour le
devenir de nos familles comme en ce
moment
merci d'y avoir pensé aussi madame la
ministre le gouvernement envisage-t-il
des mécanismes de protection pour les
enfants victimes de la perte de parents
morts au combat sanitaires merci
monsieur le député chers collègues
la parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre
désormais monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
françois jolivet vous évoquez un sujet
douloureux victimes de cette crise
sanitaire qui est un drame que vivent de
nombreuses familles face au décès d'un
proche
permettez moi tout d'abord de leur
témoigner de toute notre compassion face
à cette épreuve compassion et épreuve
rendue encore plus douloureuse par les
mesures de confinement qui entoure le
deuil
parmi ces victimes vous le soulignez il
y a malheureusement des soignants qui
ont été contaminées qui ont payé de leur
vie leur engagement pour en sauver
d'autres et vous évoqué le cas d'une
aide soignante de votre département qui
est décédé
et qu'il est ces quatre orphelins je me
joins à vous pour lui rendre hommage et
pour adresser toutes mes pensées et s'il
accepte toute aumône affection à ses
enfants comme je témoigne de la
reconnaissance de la nation à tous les
soignants qui vont au bout de leur
vocation en toute connaissance des
difficultés et des risques de leur
mission alors ces soignants décédées des
suites du coc vide oui laisse parfois
derrière eux des enfants et vous avez
parfaitement raison monsieur le député
ses enfants ils ne doivent pas être
abandonnées
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
ministère le ministre de la santé a
indiqué que les soignants contaminée par
le coït 19 bénéficieront d'un dispositif
d'indemnisation de type maladies
professionnelles les conséquences de la
maladie contractée pour ces personnes
seront traitées et en cas de décès les
ayants-droit disposeront d'une
compensation de revenus mais par
ailleurs le gouvernement est en train de
travailler pour vérifier si les
dispositifs existants sont adaptées à
toutes les situations compte tenu des
circonstances
absolument exceptionnel que nous vivons
actuellement est le cas échéant bien sûr
nous les compléteront notamment monsieur
le député nous étudierons votre
proposition sur les pépites de la nation
qui peut venir compléter ces dispositifs
qui seront pris pour venir en soutien de
ces familles
c'est à la mairie la parole est à
monsieur eric coquerel chers collègues
un big o comme ça ça nage pas ça cool tu
aurais dû lui accrocher un boulet au
pied c'est insultera s'ils sont celles
de policiers à l'ile-saint-denis à
propos d'un homme qui les avaient fui
dans la seine dans ce contexte
gravissime c'est mon devoir de
réinterroger le miz de l'intérieur sur
la question des violences policières
elles sont dénoncées depuis des années
par les habitants et associations des
quartiers populaires je veux le dire
dans cette assemblée
il y a un problème dans la police
nationale un problème persistant de
violence disproportionnée de racisme et
d'impunité
vous avez cette fois réagi vite mais
face à ce problème monsieur castaner
vous avez trop bu
et en touche expliquant par si les
violences en blâmant leurs victimes les
réduisant par là des cas particuliers
quand rob indéniable moi aussi
j'aimerais me dire qu'elles sont le fait
d'individus isolés d'evian ce serait
plus simple mais c'est faux les rires
glaçant de confort de cette vidéo
le silence qui les entoure à commencer
par le commissaire présent on montre
l'affreuse banalité la liste
interminable de violence recensés depuis
le confinement également sofiane
ramatoulaye mohamed et tant d'autres ont
subi des violences graves verbal est
souvent physiques
c'est le résultat d'une politique et
d'une violence trop longtemps toléré
voire couverte au sein de cette
institution
car les qui ne savent pas nager
les jeunes des quartiers trop
indisciplinés les noirs trop agressive
les fous trop dangereux ou trop gros
après les manifestants trop
contestataire ne sont pas des excuses
mais des stéréotypes et des prétextes
discriminant il y aurait pourtant tant à
faire pour redonner sens à la politique
à la police républicaine la réinventer
ce serait un message encourageant
adressé aux très nombreux policiers qui
tiennent portée la plus haute exigence
envers la police
c'est aussi lui témoigner de sa plus
haute importance
c'est commencer par reconnaître la
réalité et l'ampleur de ces violences ne
plus se servir de la police pour imposer
un système social injuste se mettre
enfin à former et recruter autrement
revenir à une vraie police de proximité
ma question est donc simple dit vous
comme moi qu'il ya un problème grave
si oui comment allez vous y mettre fin
merci monsieur le député la parole de
monsieur laurent nunez secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
eric coquerel
comme vous le savez la police intervient
pour faire respecter la loi et dans un
cadre qui est strictement encadrée par
la loi
elle peut dans ce cadre-là faire usage
de la contrainte de la force et c'est
bien pour cela que nous exigeons que les
textes exigent que son action ne soit
toujours proportionnée encadré justifier
c'est pour cela que nous exigeons qu'il
y a une grande responsabilité beaucoup
d'exemplarité les propos auxquels vous
faites allusion ont été tenus sur la
commune de l'île saint denis que nous
connaissons bien et vous et moi
je connais bien la seine saint denis
comme vous le savez sont des propos
racistes totalement inacceptables qui
ont été tenus après une interpellation
pour un vol en réunion je vous rappeler
que vous rappelle que le ministre de
l'intérieur le soir même dans un tweet
les a fermement condamné en rappelant
qu'il n'y avait pas de place
il n'y avait pour le racisme dans la
police républicaine l'igpn a été
immédiatement saisie par le préfet de
police et quand les fonctionnaires ont
été identifiés très rapidement ils ont
demande de suspension a été adressée par
le préfet de police après l'accord du
ministre de l'intérieur de moi même au
directeur général de la police nationale
je le redis devant la représentation
nationale évidemment le racisme n'a pas
sa place dans la police nationale
c'est un délit et compter sur notre
fermeté sur notre engagement avec le
ministre de l'intérieur pour chaque fois
que de tels propos de tels comportements
seront tenus pour qu'il y ait enquête
est évidemment sanctions quand ces faits
sont confirmés mais je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire je ne veux pas vous laisser
dire que l'image de la police nationale
serait ternie par ces faits oui c'est un
risque évidemment que l'image soit
ternie mais c'est bien pour cela que
nous réagissons avec beaucoup de fermeté
car la police nationale est une
institution exceptionnelle qui accomplit
les missions exceptionnelles pour la
consigne pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
souvent au péril de leur vie et je veux
avoir une pensée en cet instant pour les
deux motards de la direction de l'ordre
public et de la circulation de la
préfecture de police de paris
quand tu étais qui ont été renversé
lundi dernier par un individu et vous
savez que le parquet national anti
terroriste a été saisi mais je ne peux
pas vous laisser dire que ce
comportement il est généralisé dans la
police la police et le corps qui est le
plus contrôlé de la fonction publique de
l'état
il y a systématiquement dans des
investigations des enquêtes et des
sanctions quand il ya faute et ses
fautes sont heureusement rarissimes
merci
la parole était mal à marietta karamanli
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'europe est rangèrent la libye connaît
une situation de crise aiguë depuis de
nombreux mois
elle connaît une guerre civile avec des
intentions de combattants extérieur une
crise politique entre groupes dirigeants
l'absence de réponse aux besoins vitaux
de la population sur place et la menace
aujourd'hui d'une pandémie avec le coc
u19 ont l'estiment 650 mille femmes
enfants et hommes qui sont prêts à fuir
la crise et constitue une vague
d'émigration vers les côtes européennes
les autorités de la de malte ont fait
savoir qu'ils n'avaient pas les moyens
de faire face à une nouvelle vague de
migration par la mer et il appelle donc
à une opération humanitaire urgente de
l'union européenne en libye
ce qui suppose une aide alimentaire et
des soins médicaux de santé au liban le
comité des réfugiés fait a également des
premiers envois de personnes dans un
pays de l'est de guerre en guerre la
situation donc est complexe au regard du
conflit interne à la libye et de
possibles une action sur place le
conseil des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne s'est
réunie le 22 avril dernier la question
libyenne a été discutée mais le conseil
n'a pas pris de position monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous donner des informations
sur la situation exacte et la position
de la france
quelles sont les initiatives que notre
pays entend prendre en europe pour mener
une opération humanitaire en direction
des populations et des états limitrophes
mais aussi dans le cadre des autres
institutions internationales ce sujet
est à la fois politique de politique
étrangère d'action humanitaire et
montrent qu'au bien ce qui se passe
ailleurs nous concerne tous je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères oui
madame
la débuter dans l'état karamanli la
crise libyenne a changé de nature
les ingérences étrangères l'afflux de
mercenaires les violations de l'embargo
alimente une dégradation considérable de
la situation et partout en particulier
en tripolitaine
les combats s'intensifient en ce moment
même et les populations civiles sont les
premières victimes et puis cette
situation se double d'un enlisement du
processus politique qui avait été initié
à berlin en janvier dernier avec
l'ensemble des acteurs y compris les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement que sur
le président poutine le président macron
le président si si le secrétaire d'état
américain a pompé au tout le monde était
là y compris le président erdogan pour
nous mettre d'accord sur un processus
politique et celui ci n'est pas mise en
oeuvre au contraire chacun prend des
initiatives qui remettent en cause le
démarrage même du processus politique et
nous avons dans ce contexte avec nos
partenaires européens il ya quelques
jours lancé un nouvel appel à une trêve
humanitaire pendant le ramadan relayée
relayant ce sens eu l'initiative des
nations unies malheureusement cette
trêve n'est pas respectée alors qu'elle
est encore plus importante en période de
de kovy de 19 et la crise libyenne n'a
pas que très important sur les flux
migratoires et sur la situation des
migrants des réfugiés présents en libye
nous avons soutenu l'initiative de malte
qui je l'espère sera sera suivie d'effet
et nous appuyons en permanence de
l'action du hcr et de l'oim qui font un
travail remarquable auprès des réfugiés
en libye même si aujourd'hui ils ont dû
mettre en suspens les programmes de
réinstallation est de retour volontaire
en raison de la crise du coc vide
complétant cette action en aidant à la
réorientation du fonds fiduciaire
d'urgence pour que ce soit plus plus fat
plus facilement accessibles aux
populations de réfugiés dans le cadre du
coït virus
coville 19 nous mène la france a décidé
de soutenir à hauteur de 700 mille euros
la réponse libyenne à la crise sanitaire
en lien avec le ms mais la véritable
réponse si c'est la réponse à la crise
politique qui est permanent dans ce pays
depuis de nombreuses années merci
monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée
je vous remercie de sortir de manière
échelonnée prochaine séance mardi 5 mai
à 15h questions au gouvernement
la séance est levée